hey guys welcome to another session by
simply learn
in this video we learn all about nodejs
and mongodb now node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
environment for running web applications
outside the client's browser
and on the other hand mongodb is a
popularly used nosql document based
database management system
now both these technologies are crucial
in app development
so that is what this video is going to
cover
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so first we'll look at a detailed
tutorial on node.js followed by a
detailed tutorial on mongodb
so let's begin so what exactly is
node.js now consider a scenario where a
user interacts with the web application
the user only interacts with the front
end of the application but there's a lot
of work that goes behind the scenes
now in a web application there's a front
end a server and a database the front
end is developed using javascript and
frameworks like angular and react while
the server is built on java php or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
mysql or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform javascript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop io
intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single page applications
online chatting applications and other
web applications it is used by large
established companies and newly minted
startups node.js was developed by ryan
dahl in 2009 and at the same time of
this session its latest version is
v13.3.0
now that we know what node.js is let's
go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development
here are a few points first up node.js
is extremely fast being built on google
chrome's v8 javascript engine its
library is extremely fast in code
execution note package manager has
around 50 000 bundles for developers so
whatever functionality is required for
an application can be easily imported
from npm all apis of node.js library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an api to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files it
is also an open source platform and is
easy for beginners for web development
the above reasons more than justify the
popularity of node.js platform and why
it is being adopted by large number of
organizations and businesses today so
now moving on let's familiarize
ourselves with the parts of nodejs
nodejs consists of several components
now let's look at them one by one first
up we have modules now modules are like
javascript libraries which are used in a
node.js application to include a set of
functions now we can use required
function with the parenthesis to include
a module in a node.js application
node.js application has many modules to
provide basic functionality needed for a
web application some of them could be
http util fs url query string stream and
zlib next up we have console the console
module provides a simple debugging
console that is similar to the
javascript console mechanism provided by
web browsers now the console can print
messages to std out that prints standard
output messages and stdr to print the
error messages the next component is
cluster now node.js is built upon the
concept of single threading programming
a single instance of node.js runs in a
single thread to take advantage of
multi-core systems the user will
sometimes want to launch a cluster of
node.js processes to handle the load a
cluster can be added to an application
in this way here's a small code for you
the next component is global now global
objects in node.js are available in all
modules now these objects are functions
modules strings etc some node.js global
objects are mentioned in the table you
have dir name that is the directory name
file name exports module and require the
next component is error handling now
node.js applications experience four
types of errors we have the standard
javascript errors system errors user
specific errors and assertion errors now
errors in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by 0. now this error would
crash the nodejs application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you
next up we have streaming a stream is an
abstract interface for working with
streaming data in node.js streams are
objects that let you read data or write
data continuously there are four types
of streams first one is the readable
these are these types of streams from
which data can be read writable these
are the types of streams to which data
can be written
duplex these are both readable and
writable streams
lastly we have transform these streams
can manipulate the data while it is
being read or written moving on to the
next component buffer the javascript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different io operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have internal binding in this case the
error emitter executes its code inside
the error method next up is the external
binding now here the error emitter is
explicitly added to a domain via its add
method the next component is the dns the
dns module enables name resolution for
example it is used to look up the ip
addresses of host names dns module is
used to connect to a dns server and
perform name resolution by using the
method dns.resolve the dns module is
also used for performing name resolution
without a network communication by using
the method dns.lookup the next component
is the debugger node.js includes an
out-of-process debugging utility
accessible via a v8 inspector and
built-in debugging client this node.js
debugger is not feature packed but
supports simple inspection of code it
can be used in the terminal by using the
inspect keyword before the name of the
javascript file in order to inspect a
file say myscript.js you can use the
following method now that we are
familiar with all the major parts of
node.js let's go ahead and learn about
the node.js express framework
express is a flexible node.js web
application framework that provides a
wide set of features to develop both web
and mobile applications you can assume
express as a layer built on top of the
nodejs that helps manage the server and
the roots now let's have a quick look at
some of the core features of express
framework it is used to design single
page multi-page and hybrid web
applications it allows setting up of
middleware to respond to http requests
it defines a routing table that is used
to perform different actions based on
the http method and url it also allows
dynamic rendering of html pages based on
passing arguments to templates now
moving on let's take a quick example of
a simple hello world program now this is
developed using express framework to
gain a better understanding all right
first up we have the wear express now
this is used to import express framework
into our node.js application now the
app.get method is a callback function
with parameters request and response the
request object represents the http
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
http headers etc the response object
represents the http response that an
express app sends when it gets an http
request now the application will listen
to the defined port which in this case
is 8081 and variables host and port will
contain the address and the port
respectively lastly we have the
console.log which is used to show the
address and port in the command prompt
so this is what the command prompt would
look like and finally the output is
displayed on the web browser having
learned about the express framework now
let's move on and look at the node.js
use cases
now it is no doubt that node stands out
for its speed and intensive data
exchange so top industry leaders like
nasa paypal netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their services to node.js the
reasons why the company chose to use
node.js were application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is it's basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream netflix
simultaneously next up is walmart now
walmart is the world's largest company
by revenue with around 514 billion us
dollars according to the fortune global
500 list in 2019. again the reasons why
the company chose node.js with
asynchronous i o and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
io which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished nodejs is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event queues uber
uber is an american multinational
ride-hailing company offering services
that include peer-to-peer ride sharing
ride service healing and food delivery
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were asynchronous i o quick
iterations and active open source
community as mentioned earlier
asynchronous i o permits other
processing to continue before the
transmission has finished now quick
iterations now node.js is continually
being updated and added new features
that help in further improvement in the
performance of web servers and finally
active open source community resolves
many problems that an organization may
face in a particular scenario next up we
have nasa now nasa is an independent
agency of the united states federal
government responsible for the civilian
space program as well as aeronautics and
aerospace research the reasons why the
company chose node.js were reduced
access times handling of data intensive
tasks and the fact that the servers are
active 24 7. now nasa has lots and lots
of data and using node.js has really
helped them in reducing the access times
it is also continuously handling and
working with large streams of data
node.js is highly stable which helps in
keeping the server active 24 7. next up
we have paypal now paypal is an american
company operating a worldwide online
payment system that supports online
money transfers as opposed to
traditional methods like checks and
money orders the reasons why the company
chose to use node.js was the fact that
node.js has extremely fast build times
it allows tasks to be carried out with
fewer lines of code when compared to
other server technologies like java and
php and node.js being data intensive
efficiently handles a large amount of
data next up is medium medium is a
popular online publishing platform
developed by evan williams and launched
in august 2012. the main reasons why the
company chose to use node.js were a
data-driven applications now these
applications are ideal for being
interfaced with node.js servers b to run
a b tests now a b testing is essentially
an experiment where two or more variants
of a page are shown to users at random
and statistical analysis is used to
determine which variation performs
better lastly node.js server maintenance
is simpler than its counterparts moving
on to the last topic of this session
industry trends now node.js developers
are in demand across the globe since
many companies are adopting javascript
libraries according to forbes it is one
of the top 10 most in demand jobs
according to note source the total
number of node.js downloads increased by
40 percent in the last one year the use
of node.js in production has increased
dramatically since its release in 2010.
with early adopters such as linkedin
paypal and netflix among others node.js
has seen an exponential increase in its
use in web development the popularity of
node.js is also accounted to javascript
now since javascript is the most popular
language as evident from a survey
conducted by stack overflow in 2019 many
developers can start working on node.js
library with not much of a learning
curve node.js developers are being
offered better salary options than other
web technology developers according to
pay scale the average salary of a
node.js developer in india is around 6
lakhs 13 000 rupees per year the average
salary of a node.js developer across the
united states is around 105 000 us
dollars per year in this video we'll
help you install node.js on your windows
system so without further ado let's
begin the first thing you need to do is
download node.js from their official
website
so go ahead and type
download
node.js
navigate to their official website and
here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finish the installation
process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed
to do so we first open the command
prompt and then type in a few commands
to verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen v now this command returns
the version and if it returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it returns the latest
version now the final step is to update
the node package manager now this npm is
bundled with nodejs which consists of
all the repositories and packages
required for development purposes so to
do that type in the command
npm
install
hyphen hyphen
global now that we're done with the
installation of node let's go ahead and
implement a small program for that we
make use of a text editor in our case
we've installed vs code so go ahead and
download vs code once you're done with
the installation this is what vs code
looks like so go ahead and click on file
and create a new file it's going to be a
simple program where you're going to
print a hello world message on the web
browser to do that we make use of http
modules so node comes with built-in http
modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
http
equals required
and just say http within single quotes
now the http module can create an http
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method
so let's go ahead and type the code
say http
dot create
server and internally it consists of a
function
now the parameters to this function are
request and response now the response is
basically used to write to the client so
we say response dot write and here we
type in the message say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080 so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file
say
demo.js
maybe demo1.js and say save now to run
the program you have to open the command
prompt so open your command prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop on the desktop
so cd
desktop and now to run it say node
demo1.js
now you navigate to your browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed
so let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with a node.js has what's
called a single threaded event loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle
many many concurrent clients at the same
time it's just a very flexible way of
being able to scale up your support for
many clients
and then in addition to that we have the
javascript event based model along with
the javascript callback mechanism that
allows you to have this standard
approach to being able to connect with
and talk and discuss interactions
between the client
and the server
it's good to have these kind of
standards where you're not using
something that's unique to a specific
framework or a specific technology this
just makes it so it's more accessible
for everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers it
around the the concept of the event loop
and the event loop has a a an event
queue an operation completed and fire
requests threaded pull and then it'll
actually do the actual computation or
the file system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are
running node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have your framework
such as angular
on the client and that will then send a
request to the website and there's many
ways that those requests can happen
through web workers through forms and
through other interactions
but at some point a request is sent to
the server
and so these requests can be for data
they can be for deleting data they can
be for updating data they can be for
interacting with services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the cueing
and threading process that centers
around the event loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use that single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual uh request and
starts the event queue and this is where
a single threading process starts is by
queuing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the threat
within a pool so you have the queueing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pool which manages those um
threads as well
and then we have an event loop which you
know goes through actually receives and
processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually they're going to be
interacting with a system and that could
be a database it could be a cloud system
it could be an api file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server but then it's also
interact with things outside of its own
server environment
and so let's talk a little bit about
that workflow
so requests come in they go into the
event queue and they get spiraled
through the event loop and then we have
a non-blocking operators which are going
to be doing the input output polling
such as kq epoll and other services and
from there we're also going to be then
interacting with the threaded pool and
we're using the blocking operations to
manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pool is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or api or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
so let's go through what npm is
so npm itself stands for the node
package manager
no
great shakes there as the name says it's
responsible for all the packages and
modules that are bundled within node.js
so the notepad manager itself really has
two key functionalities and the first is
that reply it is a central repository
for all packages and modules which you
can then search through um online you
can go to
search.nodejs.org and you can find all
of the packages and modules that are out
there
the second is that it's also a command
line or terminal uh line utility that
allows you to install those packages so
you can actually go through and you can
see the version management and
dependencies that within those packages
and you actually can control the
packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts i like to use is the
concept of lego bricks um big fan of
lego and uh what's great about lego
bricks is that they're all individually
by themselves very small very specific
functionality
but if you actually get a whole
collection of lego bricks together you
can build like crazy cool things so
think of when you're working with the
node package manager itself is that each
of those individual pieces that you're
working with um each of those individual
packages are their own lego bricks and
by themselves you can then edit and
update and maintain that piece um
separately from the whole environment as
long as your inputs and outputs they
have really the piece where you snap the
lego in or when you connect lego to
something else
are interactive and open and well
documented then you can actually then
use those modules effectively throughout
your project
um so you can actually then be able to
do that you can do version control on
your codes and dependencies you can do
testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes i want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the mpm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js
locally then you've already installed
the package manager but you can also
access it through command line or
terminal window on your your data server
or in your server farm or in via the
cloud
if you haven't now downloaded node.js
here's the website where you can go down
to install it and there's windows and
mac versions of that
code as well with the installers which
allow you to get up and going very
quickly
uh you want to be able to run the
installer and accept all the default
settings just you know to begin with you
want to kind of have the standard setup
so that you are most familiar with the
normal settings before you start getting
to the point where you're a master and
you're tweaking things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or the terminal
window
and once you've actually installed
node.js
to verify that it's actually installed
you can write the command node dash dash
version and i'll actually then pull out
the version of node.js that you have uh
installed and then you'll be able to see
that you've got to actually up and
running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm we can do apm dash dash version
and it actually will then show you which
version of the node package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just json files if you're new
to this space json file is a structured
file format that's based on javascript
it's a very xml like format for being
able to
write instructions for the actual
package itself and so the json file
forms that you know really kind of the
the heart of each package you create
and it has all of the metadata that
you'd have about a particular object
and then it provides a root directory to
any of the applications or modules
that the package may be referencing
in addition and it has any other
additional
information about the project that adds
such as dependencies and other files
that need to be included so here we have
is an example
of a package and that would be created
using npm json script
and you can actually take this package
file as it is right here
and use um the command npm in it and
it'll actually run this package and so
you would actually have a demo
application up and running really
quickly
uh you can then go ahead if you want to
you can edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version uh
or what is the the main index script
that would be written you know these are
all things that you can edit very
quickly and easily you can just use text
editor to make any of these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using mpm and to do that
i've got three windows in front of me
right now so i have this window here
which is my terminal window
where i'll be doing all my instructions
then i also have a
folder which shows where i'll be putting
all of the files and then finally i'll
actually have a text editor in this case
i'm using vs code because it's free
but you can use any text editor you like
to be able to go in and show what the
code that's been created uh by npm in
the json file so you can actually see
what it looks like
and then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a
new project folder so i'm going to go in
i'm just going to move
into
i'm going to do
change directory
i'm going to
the project folder
and we'll see down here that we have an
empty project folder um but for this one
i'm actually going to go ahead and i'm
going to create a new directory in this
one and i'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simply lamp folder
and we are going to
move into the simplyland folder
and so we're now in the simply land
folder uh there's nothing in that right
now so the first thing we want to do is
we want to take go ahead and initialize
this folder as a project folder for
working with mpm now to do this you will
have to already installed npm if you
have no js npm comes with it
and if you want to see whether or not
you have npm installed so you can just
do npm
version
and that will actually tell you what the
version of npm you have installed is and
it also verifies that npm is installed
so i've gone ahead and i've been able to
validate that i have npm installed so
what i'm now going to go ahead and do is
i'm going to initialize this folder so
to do that you just do npm init and
you'll see that the path is that we're
already in the simplyland folder and
then when you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and
then i can show you how we can edit
those in a little bit
uh we're going to go with just say yes
to all of these just by hitting return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do you want to go ahead and create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so we go ahead and open
this up with
vs code
here we are we can actually see what all
of the information is we can go ahead
and we can actually go and update uh
this metadata if we want to i'm going to
leave it as is for right now because i
want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working
with npm
and the reason why you're using npm is
that you want to take advantage of
packages that are freely available in
the open source community that are
supported by node.js and one of those is
a package called express and express is
a lightweight framework for building out
uh web applications similar concept uh
to angular or react.js
i like using it and it's also a great
way to be able to
show how we can uh install this using
npm so to install this uh you just start
with the command npm and then you type
install
and then we type the name of the package
and we hit
enter
and it goes ahead
and what you'll actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above uh we
also have uh so this is in our json
package that is now a dependency it's
written in there
we can also go in and under our node
modules we actually see that we have
we scroll down we should see express
there it is express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use
express we can actually just come in and
we can write command npm
uninstall
i can type
express
oops i did a typo there so let's try
that again npm
uninstall
express
and couple things going to happen one is
in our json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under our node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see um that we can
easily add and remove packages
uh so let's just go ahead and i'm going
to install express again so
install
express
oops
npm install express
all right so it's gone ahead and it's
installed express
now one of the things that often happen
is that when you're working with a
package the actual json package so
you'll receive
this file
and you want to be able to go ahead and
install of the
sub modules that come with it so and you
can go through you can manually install
them like this or you can actually run
an install command so you can actually
install all of them at once i can just
show you what that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install bootstrap
which is another
popular framework
strip
and we're actually going to go with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have
express there it is right there
so we now come over to
our
new commands we can actually write the
command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and
let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just
express but we'll also see that
bootstrap has also been added
now i don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of
what's happened here now if we want to
we can actually go in here and we can
see
on in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a
setup for a base uh initialization of
your package going through to creating
the first package uh being able to set
up and control the naming convention for
each of the items within the metadata
that provides the instruction for
the package how you can then put in
dependencies such as express and
bootstrap how you can install them and
remove them and actually use do all this
through command line if you have any
questions
please let us know
so let's kind of jump into the express
js framework
so express.js is a really flexible
node.js and web application framework it
is just something you can spin up very
quickly and built both web and mobile
applications just a really great tool
you know i use it all the time for
building up my own applications
the thing that's so great about it is
it's really simple and so it's not going
to be as have all the the functionality
that you would have in maybe a larger
scale http service
but with that said it does come with a
lot of functionality that allows you to
not only create websites but you can
also do apis and other routing calls
very very nice
so let's go through some of the features
that express.js have
so as i mentioned before it allows you
to build simple web applications and
that can be either a single page
application or a multi-page application
um it also allows you to do middleware
uh requests and responses so for
instance if you want to do an api
and have that be part of your middleware
you can actually set that up real
quickly in fact in the demo that we'll
do later on we'll actually be building
out four different api calls that you'll
be able to do and you'll be able to see
how you can use express.js for that
um and that then turns allows you to be
able to see how express.js can help
manage some of the routing of the
different um http methods and that you'd
be using via url
and then finally it's just a great way
of being able to dynamically test the
work that you are developing so you can
actually build out a solution and test
it right away in express js have it in a
single packet and then once you get to a
certain point you can then check in the
whole packet
even have it as part of your container
and then check that into your
main project
and then if somebody else wants to then
take on the work they can then just pull
that in
so let's kind of go step through you
know a basic example so here we actually
have a full script for creating a simple
hello world and this includes installing
express.js
defining the ports it's going to run on
as well as a basic piece of code so the
first thing you want to do is actually
go ahead and define how you want to
install express.js and this is called
the very first variable which is
requiring that express be installed as
part of node packet manager
npm will then pull in the latest version
of express if you need to define a
specific version of course you can do
that
in this example we're just going to pull
the latest one and then we'll go ahead
and with the second line which will then
install express and when you do it once
you'll see how quickly it installs onto
your local development machine
the next parameters are actually a
callback function so if something
actually happens when you go to the
website where we're going to run our web
application you want something to pop up
and in this instance we'll say hello it
will pop up
the third block is all about where you
would actually go ahead and host your
code and so in this one you'll see that
the
server is going to listen and listen to
port 8081 so that's what that function
actually there defines
and then you can either put in uh the a
specific host address
in the demo you'll actually see how we
define that for localhost but you can
actually then point this to a production
host environment if you want
and then the final line here is a
command that actually sent a
script to your terminal window telling
you that which port and which host that
you are listening to so let's see what
that would look like so here we go see
have our terminal window and we're
actually able to then
run the hello world js script that we
just
wrote and then once we do that it'll
actually then post that we have an
example app listening at
and here we don't have a
web domain address and we do have the
port 8081
and in our browser window it says hello
world
so that's a quick breakdown of
express.js now let's jump over and do a
demo
so the first thing we want to do to get
express up and running on our system is
we have to have node.js installed so
we're just going to do a google search
to let you know where you can find
node.js it's actually at nodejs.org
so we select that link that will take us
to nodejs.org and there are two types of
downloads one is the current download
which has
the latest features and then there's a
more stable version that if you're new
to node.js i'd recommend you to download
next we want to find a text editor and
we're going to go with visual studio
code or vs code as known
it's an open source solution from
microsoft that runs across all the
leading platforms this will default to
our windows platform but you can run it
on mac os and linux as well i really
like it it's a great code editor it
comes a lot of extensions and it's open
source
and next thing you want to do is because
we're going to be developing apis we
want a way to be able to visualize those
apis quickly and a great tool is a
product called postman again open source
and so you can go out and go to
postman.com uh top right hand corner
you'll see a bright orange download
button where you can actually go and
head and download and install postman
and that will allow you to be able to
access
all of your apis that we're going to be
creating in express
you can actually use other tools such as
apigee as well for visualizing your apis
but this one's just great to get you
started so let's go ahead and open up
vs code and we want to go ahead and open
a new folder where we're going to have
our project we're going to just for
our demonstration here we're going to
put this on the desktop you wouldn't
normally do this but it will work fine
here i'm going to create a folder i'm
going to title the file the node express
and we'll select that folder that now
becomes the root folder for our project
in visual studio
we don't really need the the welcome
screen anymore so we're going to get rid
of that
and one of the things that is great
about working with vs code is you can
actually have the terminal window up and
running as well so let's go ahead and
open that so it's running at the bottom
of our screen and this gives us a little
bit of space
and the first thing we want to do is
actually turn convert the folder in
actually into a project running node.js
so we're going to use npm in it and
they'll actually initialize the project
we have another video that explains how
to use npm or node package manager and
you can go ahead and find that um in our
library here
but as we go ahead and we do that you'll
actually see that it will create the
default package uh json file which has
uh the
name of the folder is the default name
of the package but you can actually go
in and edit any of these documents
we want to create a default file that's
called index.js
this is where we're going to write most
of our scripts that allow us to work
with node.js
and the first is writing a script that
allows us to install express and
we'll use the node packet manager to
actually pull and install express
and you can default to specific versions
of express if you want and we're just
going to go with the latest one so we're
just going to put in express and then
we'll go down into terminal window and
say npm install
save express and this will install
express so we can actually test out the
code we're working on
and let's take just a moment to install
great thing we're working with node
package manager is that once we finish
with our package here we can actually
wrap it all up and send it over
to any other developer that we're
working with and then you can actually
run the the package and actually have
exactly the same code installed
and there we are we have everything
installed and ready to go
you can see we actually have all of the
modules installed you see that we
actually have express installed as well
and we also want to then make this an
app
and then we'll do app
listen
to port 3000 so this is by default we're
going to be running from our local host
which is http server running on
this test machine
and we're going to have express for this
project
run on port 3000
and in the once we actually run the
script we'll actually post into the
console
window a
piece of text saying server started on
port 3000
so we're going to go ahead and save this
file
a little control s to save these files
so let's go into localhost in our web
browser so localhost colon sorry yeah
it's localhost column3000
and you'll see nothing has been reached
that's because we actually haven't done
anything to initialize the script so we
want to come in and we're going to go
nodeindex.js and hit return and as you
can see now we have a message in our
console window that means that yep there
we go we actually have everything up and
running
so we can actually see that the service
is running not a very pleasant message
so let's go ahead and change that
so let's change that to
app get
and
[Music]
res
and so if you use the get message that's
change
what we'll print
and we'll type hello
there
exclamation mark
and we save that
and we refresh the screen
oh nothing happening yet because we
didn't run the script let's go back in
and we'll run the script node index.js
and now what you'll see is if we refresh
there we are we have our new hello there
message
all right well let's actually start
building some apis in this environment
so to be able to build the apis we want
to be able to pull
content so we can actually
create a new file called users.js
and we're going to create
we're going to go ahead and create a a
user's json packet and a json packet is
essentially
a
an array um
consider it like a small database and in
this array we're going to have four
objects each object is going to have
three pieces of metadata we have an id
name and email and they'll be
id one two and three and then you'll see
that the names will be
john smith and we'll make up a couple of
others
i'm just kind of giving them arbitrary
email addresses
it's just for our demo here
let me grab this copy it and kind of
speed up
the script writing time
there we go
and let's just change what we need
one of the things that's nice with
working with the visual studio
code vs code is there's lots of plugins
and so one of the default features is
that if you
select a variable it'll actually look
for the same variable in the script so
you can if you need to you can actually
change them all in
once
but we don't need to worry about that
right now we're just creating a json
packet so we have four items
id one two three and four
for john smith and jack and chris
all right so that's our
array string and we're going to then
make sure that we can export that as
users so we can actually now whenever we
select the term users in our scripts
it'll actually pull in this packet
all right looking good
now let's go over to our main index.js
file and we're just going to go ahead
and we want to like
store where
the the api is going to be so we're
going to create a
folder called routes and then a
subfolder called api
and then we'll call a file in there
called users.js so as we're updating our
scripts we know where to
pull the data from
it's just a standard way of being able
to pull out the values so in here we're
going to say
in this instance express is required
for our scripts
and we're going to also say that router
within express router
correct
naming convention
and the script is case sensitive we'll
also want to
create a value later on that will have a
unique id so we're actually going to
pull in a uuid
package that will actually then allow us
to install
unique identifiers so we use node
package manager to install
uuid
again this is a great example of how you
can
go from nothing to something very
quickly
with exp
node.js because we installed express we
installed uuid and we're off to the
races
so let's have users require
the path for where
our api is going to be located
all right so let's do a basic
get
which will be to pull the record and
we're going to have it pull
all the records so router.get and
we're going to require it to pull all of
the records in the json packet that we
created
so there should be
four items to come back
save that
looks good
make sure that users is consistent
there's our adjacent packet
and
yep everything looking pretty good
all right let's go back to index
and we're going to switch out
this function here from just a generic
get with a generic
statement to
actually being able to pull in the users
so
we have to go
map use express.json
lab dot use
url encoded
extended
false
amp dot use
api
users so
we're going to be pulling them all from
the same location
require
and where we have our api
scripts
okay
and then let's go ahead and open up
postman because we're going to actually
use postman to actually show us what the
results look like because right now the
results
won't show up appropriately
um in our browser window
so placement again is just a api
management tool if you used apogee or
other similar tools that are on the
market meal soft
you'll see it's very consistent again
this is open source
and
what you want to be able to do is you
can actually go and actually go to the
path where the api is stored and then
you can use all the different types of
commands within
your
environment to be able to you know test
out the scripts so let's go ahead and
create a
new project new request and we're gonna
go with the default get but there's
actually quite a lot of different
commands we can use
and these are just http commands
and we're gonna type in the request and
in this instance
it's going to be
let's run our script first
script i think we're good
let's make sure we're exporting the data
correctly
okay
so we want to run our script so let's do
node index.js and that will
run the changes that we just created so
we can now come over to get we select
api um localhost colon3000
slash api
users
when we do
that brings back
the
json package with our four
entry points
there there's all four of them
so that's your
first action
now let's kind of get this a little bit
tighter let's actually go in and see if
we can filter by id
so we're going to go in and we're going
to modify our script so it's going to be
route
and then we're going to put in the
filter and in this instance it's going
to be id
which would allow us to be able to just
put a backslash against the
end of the url string we just had and
put in a number or a unique identifier
and then that will actually then allow
us to pull in that unique record
okay
plus the data
okay so if found
i'm going to
take the json and
print it
so we're going to filter here against
user id
and then
publish the results
else
if that doesn't work then we'll just
have a
generic
error message
we shouldn't see this though in the
demos we're creating
this is just
good practice
so save that
and let's go ahead and rerun
our node index file against that folder
and now we can actually come in here and
we do backslash one and that will give
us just one record
and we could change that to 2 or 100 in
this instance and if it's 100
we'll just get a bad request error
message
there's two
all right
so that's
get so be able to pull all the records
we need to filter against one specific
record against a specific parameter in
this instance it was id so let's go
ahead and create a new user so that what
we can do for this is we're going to use
the post um command from http to
actually push and post data into
the data source the data sources are
json packet which means that we'll have
to then push a new record into the json
package using our array statements
because json is just essentially an
array
and so we're going to
post and when we do this we have to
create a unique id so this is where we
have to reference the uid
i'm going to do a v4 unique id
which will be
four groups of four so these 16
characters
and then
we'll have
name
and email will post
okay looks good
okay so
if
new user
input dot name
and
new user
dot email
and then you want to return
the results
okay
all right and so users
dot
push so
we posted which is http statement and
then pushing into the
the jason packet array
okay
okay it's looking good
all right so
i think we're good
let's go ahead and rerun our script
nodeindex.js
that allows us to do that so let's go
over to postman so we can actually
connect to the url i'm going to change
the http statement to post
and
get rid of that go back to users now if
we just do this
nothing's going to happen so we actually
have to go in and we have to update the
body
and this would be the content that'll be
passed through and we're going to go
through with a raw
statement here
and we do json this will be
that's the packet we're sending so let's
go ahead and the records we want to
update we only have to update two which
is one is name and the second is email
we don't have to do an id because we're
using uuid to generate an automatic one
for us
and we're going to create records for
staff and her email address is steph
gmail.com
yep looking good
okay so let's go ahead and send that
we sent it
and if we look at the bottom we can
actually now see that we have five
records so a new one's been added we
have our unique id at the top
and then we have name and email which
are the ones that we just created for
staff and staff at gmail.com
all right
so that's posting now the next thing you
want to do is to update a record so that
means we need to select an id
and then be able to update the content
and for that we're going to use the http
put command
so we'll use id as our way to be able to
filter
and then we'll be able to update against
that filter
so
construct found
because
users
and then
we'll have it going is
user's id
so we know how to get the correct record
and then pass the record back
onto the screen so we know what we're
editing
so if
so we've found
i'm going to update
the user
and i'm going to go ahead and pull
information from the body for what will
be updated
and for each
diffuser id
then pass
the integer
okay
so this is our values to pass against
the id
and in this instance
make sure that we're updating the values
of
username
so if we are
updating user
and we're just updating the username we
want to
make sure that that's the value that
gets updated
and then we also want to do user email
we don't want to update the id because
it's going to remain unique and
consistent
okay i'm going to make sure that
everything is pushed to the
json package
and then we'll also have a message
saying that
the field has been updated in the json
package
okay
all right so run that script again
and looks good let's go to our folder
let's change the http
post let's put it as get
just so we can see that we have
uh all of the values in the array from
the jsonpacket
and now we want to say put which allows
us to
update just
one record
so let's go ahead and select one record
we'll select it1 so
we have one record we can go ahead and
for name we can change this
so let's go ahead and change these
so now you see that the email has
changed so we have staff
as the new account
all right our final api that we're going
to create is to delete an account and in
many ways it's actually a very basic api
because what we're doing is we're
grabbing the id and then we're saying
that all the associated records with
that id
within
that row
as it were in the table just to delete
the whole row
and so
we want to use again
our id as
the unique value that we're
pulling against
so we're going to if users are found
and we're going to
filter those users
i'm going to do that filter against user
id pass that
and
then go and
post a message to our adjacent packet
saying
user
deleted
no
generic message if things fail
okay let's save that and we'll
see we go ahead and we're using we're
just deleting the record now
and we're going to do it by filtering
against a unique id
and then you will then just eliminate
that record
and pass the message that has been
the account has been deleted
okay
so we save that let's go run our script
nodeindex.js
good okay has come over here and
we're going to
show that we can pull any of the
accounts so let's just take one of them
one that's good
so let's go ahead and we're going to
change
the http command to delete
and we actually have to
select an account so we just do one
when we do that it'll actually delete
that record and here we are um it says
that the user has been deleted and we
now only have
three records in the jsonpacket
and we can pull all the records
and you'll see that there's only three
so being able to
uh pull all the records from adjacent
package we'll be able to create a record
update a record and delete a record
and we can just step through so here's
our json package that we get created
originally again this is just an array
it's just a different way of setting up
the array
and then we have our index files which
identifies what are the apps that need
to be installed and where are the apis
going to be serviced out of
and that we're going to be doing this on
the port 3000
and again these are additional tools
that we need to make sure and that we
have up and running um in our script and
so the first script was to get all the
um the records seconds to filter against
a user id for just a specific record
and then for creating a record we
actually went in and we used the uid
tool to create a unique identifier and
then we posted in the data for the new
records we did something similar with
updating the record we didn't have to
update the user id we just had to update
the values in the two fields that we
needed to be updated
in this case name and email
and the final step was to go ahead and
delete a record so these are all
apis that you can now pull into your own
application so you can use them in web
applications or you can actually go
ahead and use them in other applications
such as mobile applications
local applications and other scripts and
this really allows your application to
become
more scalable
and more useful
hello and we're going to go through and
do our demo of building a restful api
with node.js so the first thing we want
to do is go ahead and install all the
correct pieces of software we'll start
with node.js so let's do a google search
on node.js and you'll find that
node.js is at
nodejs.org so we select that link
and that's going to take us to the
node.js website and there are two
versions of node.js you can download
there's the stable version and then
there's the latest version i'd go with
the stable version you'll find it
available in windows mac awares and
linux as well
and if we go to the next piece of
software you want to go ahead and
install the text editor of your choice
i'm going to use visual studio code vs
code it's an open source solution it
works on all leading platforms
works really well i like it a lot
microsoft did a good job with this i
also really like it that it's open
source but there's lots of extensions
you can get for vs code um so it's a
great text editor
and we'll also need postman postman is a
tool that allows us to be able to view
the apis that we're going to create so
let's go ahead to postman.com and again
it's another uh solution you can
download for free and so we're gonna go
ahead and select the download button
and it will automatically detect which
os you're on so in this case it's gonna
be windows but you can also get mac and
linux as well so we'll go ahead and
download those
and once we have everything installed
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a project in vs code and that's
actually really easy to do all you have
to do is create a folder
and we do this right off our desktop
and we're going to call the folder node
rest api and we'll select that folder
and you'll see on the left hand column
that we have the new folder that we
created and we still have the vs code
welcome screen we're going to get rid of
that we don't need that anymore so
let's go ahead and one of things i like
with vs code is you can actually toggle
the terminal window so let's go ahead
and
open up the terminal window so we can
actually run that at the same time and
so we're going to
move our cursor to the folder we just
created and there we are you can see
that
and what we're going to do now is we're
going to initialize this with node
package manager
to make this a package
and it's going to go ahead i'm going to
ask for a name we're just going to go
with the default so we're just going to
say yes yes to a couple of these
yep enter
enter enter
enter and it's okay
yep enter
all right so now we have a new file and
this is our json package it has all the
defaults in it we can go in and modify
these if you want to i have no need to
for this exercise but you may want to
for the solution that you're putting
together
and we're going to create a new file
called index.js and this is going to be
the reference file that's in the json
package
for npm
and here we're going to put in our
solutions that we absolutely have to
have for this to run so we're going to
install express and express
is a web service application but it's
very flexible and one of the things that
we're going to use it for today is build
apis
so in our terminal window we're going to
type npm install
save express
this will install express locally on our
machine
and takes a few minutes but it's going
to go and download all the latest
features this is going to be the latest
version of express you can if you want
to um specify a specific version of
software
for these examples there's no need to do
that
so you'll see that everything has been
installed we expand the the node module
we can scroll down and indeed yep there
we are we see express has been installed
along with some other
pieces that are useful
all right so that's our first piece and
the next
is we're going to define our app and our
app is going to
use express
and we want express as a local host on
our local machine on port 3000 so we've
identified port 3000 as the default port
for our application
and
we are going to now create
a an array
for some movies
i'm going to have id title director and
release date
exception great movie
and director christopher
nolan
and that was released
in 2010 yes 10 years ago
okay so we're going to do an a couple of
items here and just so that we
have some more than one entry in our
array and array is a javascript
uh you can think of it as a very simple
table which allows us to have structured
data
you can also do a json file you can also
connect to
a database mongodb or something like
that
2019.
okay so we have two movies in our
little array
maybe more than enough right now
a key part is that we have a consistent
structure for the array of id titled
director and release date
and so we're going to
create uh two
apis one is going to be a get api where
we'll get the list
of the items in our api and the second
will be a post where we'll be actually
pushing in a new item so let's go ahead
and start with the get and what we want
to do is we're going to say get slash
movie
and
we are going to
have this run as an api and so
what we'll do is we will test this in a
moment
uh this will be running from our web
browser and actually we'll probably open
up postman and run this through postman
so
okay
that pause all the movies
and we'll do a another um
get in a moment where we'll filter by
movie id but let's just get them all for
right now
and we are going to
listen
on a server port in this instance it's
going to be port 3000
and
we already had defined the port as a
variable earlier um which
um so we're just referencing the
variable and the port number is the step
the
top in line four
just a text string that's going to get
put to the terminal window
and it is going to dynamically
grab the port the value from the
variable from 3000
and place it in our text string easy
and we want to save the file
and now we're going to go ahead and run
it so we're going to do node index.js
that runs the script
and tells us that we're listening on
port 3000 that's great
that means now that we should be able to
go into postman
and
grab the data from an api
so here's postman if you've not used it
before it's a great tool for being able
to manage apis i strongly encourage you
to have a go with this so we're going to
get the get command and you've done any
applications web applications you
probably
use get and post uh for the data um that
you're
pulling and pushing from forms online
same principle
so we want to go ahead and we're gonna
go and
grab get i'm going to type in localhost
and
it's going to be colon 3000
slash
movies because that's the
the name of the
file
and we hit send and
what we get as a response
is
the
data in our query
sorry in our array here we go so there's
our array
and the data values have been pulled
back by postman
that's great
so now we want to go ahead and add a
movie
to our array
and we're going to do that we're going
to use the
post
command
and get and post our http commands
and so we're going to use movies
and
in this instance
we're going to
push the value
into
our list
so construction movie requires we're
going to need
a structure here and that structure is
going to be
the information that's in there the body
and then we're gonna
push to
the log
our terminal window
and push
so here we're using
push
and that's a term in for arrays within
javascript where we push the data into
the actual array itself
there are lots of ways of being able to
control data within an array and if
you're new to arrays with javascript i
strongly encourage you to
learn more about them there's just an
awful lot you can do with them
and then we want to have a validation
message come up on the screen saying yes
movie has been added to the list so
we'll save what we've just created
and we don't save it it won't show up
and then we're going to re-run
the
node index.js file
you can see this we've created here
already
a an api that allows us to pull and push
data
in and out of a variable
okay so let's go back and we're going to
change the
header from being get to being push
so we're going to use sorry not push our
post so we're going to select post and
then what we want to do is the
value inside of the body
and so let's go over
and we want to select body
and we're playing text
and select json so it's going to be
structured
and so here we will essentially copy
the structure we have here so let's go
ahead and just
copy these elements
and we have to give it an id because we
don't have an auto generated id so we're
going to make this id
three
and then
and it's going to be a number three
and then you want to put in
title
new movie
opening
director
[Music]
and
we'll have this as
i don't know
new
director
not very creative here today
and then
we need to put in a date
so release underscore
date let's just put in a date
uh today's date will be fine
um just so you know that we're not
formatting the datecon list
so let's go ahead and we'll select send
and this will actually go and we can see
boom movies been added to our list
then we can go back and let's go ahead
and validate that so we're going to
change from post to get
use the same
and
now we go to below
oh looks like we put an error in
our formatting
so let's go
to
pass the json
and pause it using express
and this will
clear up any formatting issues
so
app.use express json
express
url encoded
extended
false
and this should help us pass
our
value
and then we'll rerun that script
make sure you save the previous file
otherwise it won't run the new script
all right looking good so let's go back
and
let's go back to
our
localhost 3000
movies
and there's only two values here
so what we need to do now is change from
get to post
we'll go to body
and what we're going to do is we want to
have
raw jason
and
what we want to do is capture the values
that we have below
and insert
this
file into this new
json packet
into
our
array you can actually just copy that
it's a little bit cheating but it's
remain same so let's go ahead
and
[Music]
get everything consistent
then we'll change the number to three
we're creating a unique title badging
sorry new title it doesn't need to be
unique just the id needs to be unique
so titled new movie
director change it to new director
i'm going to change the
date i'm not doing any formatting on the
date so i can get any date any number
really
hit save
movie has been added to our list
so it's been added but now let's go back
to get and let's see if we can actually
see the third entry and scroll down
and there we are we've actually pushed
that
json package into our array
so we now have three items in
the hoping added fire our api
okay
so
now let's go ahead and search
our movie database i guess we only have
three entries but you know we want to be
able to so we can do that by using the
get command and what we'll be doing is
we'll be validating against
a specific id number
so we have three
and we're going to
validate against just the id number
in this instance
the way to do it is through the url so
beforehand we had localhost colin 3000
slash movie
now we're adding in uh slash movie slash
and then whatever number of that will
actually filter against the id and
that's essentially what we're doing here
right now
so we're going to go into if movies
dot id again we're using the id value to
actually pull from our arraylist
with my variables and arrays mixed up
here today
and then once we actually have the value
we'll actually post back as a json
packet
and
if we have any errors then what we'll do
is we'll throw up message movie not
found so
there we are we're gonna pull against an
id
and we should be able to then pull that
up through postman
into
our terminal window
again the reason why we're using postman
is that this is actually just showing
the values going back and forth we're
not having to render a whole web page
it's extremely fast very efficient
[Music]
so we saved and rerun our script
all right let's go back and what we're
going to do is we're going to change the
value so we're going to hit send here we
are we see all of our movies using the
get command now what we're going to do
is we're going to use a look filter on
just
id2 which is the irishman so do slash 2
and there we are we have just the
information on the irishman
so now you can see how you can create a
simple search
all right
so the final action we want to do is to
delete a record
in our array and so
we can go ahead and do that
and we're going to use the uh
delete command to actually do that so
we'll be able to
push
um
in a record we've been able to
view records filter guide games records
now we're going to go ahead and do
delete and so we can do app delete and
then we're going to filter by
specific id number
and when we do this we'll actually then
uh when we put in the url path which
will be localhost coding3000 slash movie
slash and then the id number so this is
inside that one or two probably use two
that will then
delete from
our array
the record for the argument
and save our files
i do have a shortcut and a keyboard
shortcut of control plus s
to save files on windows
or command plus s on my mac
and
once we've deleted a record we want to
send a message saying the movie has been
deleted
all right so we want to go ahead
and
let's just check our code
good save our file
and we want to rerun
the
index.js file
yep
rerun okay let's go to postman
and grab
the delete
so again we're filtering against the
movie id and then we'll delete that id
okay so we went against the argument and
we hit send
and there it is
now we're going to change
the command to delete
so we hit
one we'll actually delete conception
movie has been deleted it's great
and let's go ahead and grab
our use get to pull in all the movies
that
are listed and it's not going to find
movie number with their id1 it's not
there anymore
and if we get all the movies
we see we only have one movie and that's
the irishman and so our delete function
has worked
there we are so we've installed express
we're using express to build all of our
applications we have our app running on
port 3000
we are using express
to pass the json
effectively back and forth we have a
simple array that array is then being
used to create an api to pull the
details then we're being able to add a
movie then search for a movie uh
filtering against an id
and then
we can actually finally go ahead and
delete a movie
all this using express.js
today we're going to be covering node.js
authentication using jwt or json web
tokens so let's get started so
why are we going to go down this path so
let's cover the key things that you need
to be asking yourself such as what is a
json web token
what is the value of using a json web
token and then what does the actual
structure of the jwt look like
and then let's go through some use cases
of where you'd actually use jwts uh both
in the enterprise and uh
in the real world
and then finally we're actually going to
go through a demo on how you can
actually install a jwt
using express and node.js
so let's dive into what actually is a
json web token
so a json web token is actually based on
an open standard it's one that you can
actually go ahead and research
and it allows a
definition of a compact self-contained
way of being able to securely transmit
information between parties using a json
object an adjacent object is a
javascript array and it's very compact
it's a very tight way of being able to
send data back and forth
the thing that's great about using a
json web token is that the information
itself is encrypted and it can only be
verified and trusted through a public
private key pair and we'll get into that
about how you can actually get to those
so you know why would you actually want
to go ahead and use a json web token are
there other formats that you can use
well yes there are other formats you can
use but what's great about jwt is that
it is a great way to be able to pass
data from http servers so if you're
building a web application and you have
a web location where you need to pass
authentication over using a jw2 is a
great way to be able to do that
so for instance you may have a number of
enterprise applications that run across
your cloud environment you may have some
enterprise applications that run in your
data center and you want to have
people come in such as your employees or
your customers authenticate once and
then be able to have their id transition
from one to the next uh jwt is a great
way to do that the content is extremely
secure and we'll get more into that in a
moment but um it is the highest level of
security you can have right now
and the final great thing about working
with jwt is that the actual tokens
themselves are very well documented and
so there's actually a lot of passes that
you can use so being able to add in jwt
into your application is very very easy
to do which makes it very easy for you
to actually
implement kind of large scale
authentication and authorization and so
authorization is a key word there that's
something that you're probably coming
across
a lot instead of just being out identify
who you are we want to be able to
authorize what you have access to
so let's have a look at the structure of
a jwt there are several key elements um
the first is the header and that's
actually going to break down um what
kind of token it is by default it's
going to be a gwt token and what is the
signing of algorithm so sha 512 is a
very complex and secure algorithm and
certainly the one that i would recommend
that you use
you can even go higher than that but um
sha 512 is a great place to start
and then you have the payload and the
payload is the information that's been
actually encrypted within the web token
so in this instance we have a name the
admin time type
sub name um just really you can put
whatever kind of information you want in
there as long as it's applicable
to the
service that you're passing the data
into
and then you have your
signature which is
um encoded header and payload with the
algorithm that you've sent so in this
instance it's sha 512 algorithm
so let's look at some of the use cases
that you'd have for jwt
so a couple of use cases would be
authorization so say for instance
you have a application and you want to
be able to authorize somebody to have
access to different parts of the
application
jwt is a great way to be able to encrypt
that data and be able to pass that data
back and forth
examples would be jumping from different
parts office 365 and be able to have
access to different features within the
system
and then another area would be if you're
doing information exchange so
information is being securely exchanged
from one person to another so a
blockchain scenario a multi-um
distributed environment where you want
to be able to have a way to be able to
securely transmit data back and forth
and know that that data is being
encrypted is another good example
so with that
let's take a pivot and we'll go ahead
and we'll look at creating a demo
using our standard stack of node.js and
we'll use express and postman
and these are tools that you may already
be familiar with if you've seen other
videos that we've created in this series
and we'll go ahead and create a jwt
token
so let's go into our demo of how to
create a jwt json web token there's
gonna be some tools that we need to get
started with the node.js is the first so
let's go ahead and
find node.js at nodejs.org and you can
either download windows mac or linux
code
obviously you'd install the one that
would be for your operating system
and the next tool that we want to
install is a text editor we're going to
use visual studio code or vs code
go to
code.visualstudio.com download this this
will run on
mac windows and linux
really great
text code editor
and then we're also going to use postman
postman is a tool that allows you to
access and view apis that we'll be
creating with express and you go to
postman.com hit download
and again there's versions of postman
for all leading operating systems
and have those installed and up and
running
so we're going to go ahead and let's
open up visual studio code
and we're going to start by creating our
project
let's go full screen on this get rid of
the welcome screen
and that's going to open up a folder
where we'll actually have our project
we're going to put this on our desktop
for right now let's go create a new
folder and we'll call this node jwt
[Music]
for json web token
select that folder
and we're going to want to go ahead and
use npm to initialize
this folder for
for node and so let's get rid of the
welcome screen again and let's go ahead
and one things i love about
vs code is going to run the terminal
window right from in here so let's go
ahead and select npm init
or he knows to pull from the folder that
we're in
and we're just going to select
yes here in a second
for our
yep let's go ahead and create that and
you'll see that the packet has been
created
and there is a json packet with just
default information about the npm
package that we created for a node
and we're going to go ahead and create
an index.js file that's what we'll been
pulling from the package
and the index.js files we're going to
actually rewrite all of our code and
what we want to do right now is install
express
and express is going to be used to
create the apis that will be able to
test our
jwt
against and then we'll also want to
install
a
jwt
um
file so let's call this json web token
and from our terminal window we'll just
go ahead
and install both of those and do that by
typing npm install
save and then we're going to put express
and json web token
express and json web token
and we'll just go ahead and let those
install
only takes a moment for those to get
installed
all right we're up and running okay
so let's go ahead and start bringing in
some of our apps so we're going to
create
an express app
and we're going to use the
get http
header to
have everything and go from the we're
going to actually have everything
running on our local host and we're
going to run everything off port 3000
we'll do that in a moment here but we'll
have everything running off a sub
folder called api it's where our web
applications can be running from
and we'll put in a message that
hey there to show that everything's up
and running
okay
and
[Music]
save that
and save you can do control plus s to
save your files
and as you can with a lot of windows
applications and i encourage you to do
that a lot so let's go ahead and open up
postman we're not even going to go to
our web browser on this one
and open up postman
it takes a moment to run the first time
and it comes
and postman again is a tool for being
able to
manage api calls and
so you don't have to write a script
so here we are
and we can go in here and we can
that's where we're going to write our
script but we have to
do a couple things first let's let's get
everything running so we want to
listen on for port 3000 that's we're
going to run everything off of
and
in the console log we'll actually throw
in a message to confirm that we are
running on
uh everything is up and running we'll
just say okay
uh server started on port 3000
again we're gonna be running everything
off localhost so you'll be able to see
this
um and this is as you imagine just a
test environment so let's go down into
our console we'll run this script node
index.js to run the script it runs
really fast not a whole lot going on
there
and we're having everything running off
the api files so let's go and we'll type
in under our get localhost
colon
like slash api
and we hit the
there's lots of different http headers
um we can use we're gonna use get for
right now
send that
and
hey there welcome to the api service
so to be clear this is just an api we're
creating right now this is not jwt we'll
get into that right now
all right
so
we want to be able to post data
and uh post is actually pushing data in
so we're going to go into uh we're going
to create a login screens again again
this is all api so it's not real but uh
you're good you get the point
then just construct a user
and let's go ahead and what we're doing
here is we're creating
a
an array
of a random user and they can have a
name of id1 that they have users can
have an id value which is one um a
username value which is gonna be john
and an email value of john gmail.com
and then we'll make this
a
json
web token jwt signing and they'll have
to sign with their user
and
this is going to use a secret key which
will be our hash
our hash 512
token
and
respond to the json with the token
okay so let's see now
okay and we're going to
hamp. and this will be our post
api
posts
and what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to jump from one app to
another app and you'll be able to see
how we can move the token with it
and the message will read
post
created
all right
so let's just run that script
index.js
runs real quick
okay
so if we come over here and we go to
posts
and hit send
and say message posts created
good
so let's go ahead and try that again
and we want to go to the
login
so go from one app to another app
select post
and
here in the login
we should be able to
request the token
this will be our gwt token
and we hit send we should get our token
and here you can see the the whole token
is encrypted
it's that huge long line
very unique
and
now we want to be able to go in and say
okay
let's verify
the token so
we've gone ahead and we've created the
token but now we need to as we go from
app to app we need to actually verify
the token so we're going to get an error
message if we don't verify the token
correctly
so i'm going to put in a function to
verify
the token
and
we're going to
create a bearer header
value
which will be
the headers and the authorization for
that
and if type of bearer header
i'm going to have it if it's not correct
it'll be undefined
otherwise
this part token
it will be split
and we're going to require the token
for a very token
else
send status
403 okay so very token is what we're
going to be calling against
to verify our token i'll show you how
that works in just a moment
and this will be to authorize
and to authorize we'll need to actually
go ahead and
use the token so we can actually
put in here
all right so i think
everything's looking pretty good
oh and
if things if we get the error message
means that it's we'll see the message
forbidden if we don't put in the code
correctly so let's
double check that everything is looking
good i'm going to verify that the token
is required
okay
so if it is then jwt dot verify
[Music]
and this will
connect our token appropriately
and we'll be able to
put that in as a part of our secret key
and if it is successful
and put in
that message there
and we're also going to play in the
authorization data
yep looking good
as you can see a lot of the work is just
making sure that everything is aligned
up correctly
okay so let's run our code node index.js
there we go nice and fast
and
i'm going to go in and localhost
api posts
we'll change this to post
so it's one api which is the api posts
which is
up here
we'll hit send
and you can see that we have the error
code forbidden has come up which is what
we were expecting because we haven't
been able to put in a secret key
and
put in the comment that i've forbidden
as we're stepping through the code
and now what we can actually do is we
can go back and we can grab the token
and here is our token below
and we just want the token itself we
don't need the wrappers
and copy that
come over here
and if we write again it can say
forbidden but
we're going to
author into
our
headers
we can put in authorization
and then the value
we'll do bearer and then the key
and once we do this
we now get all of the data that we were
asking for pulled back
which is exactly what we wanted
so you can see here how we can actually
securely
use a jwt to pass values back and forth
across the application
okay and we hit
authorization and we select that and
approve it yep we keep authorizing so if
you're authorized and you don't get the
data
okay so we have everything against the
api and we have one application which is
called api post we have another
application called api plugin and we're
able to move the data back and forth
using
our secret key in our jwt token
and we have everything running on port
3000 of our local host server
and that's our demo
so first of all let's cover why you'd
want to go through this tutorial so
we're going to cover what my sql is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with my sequel and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my sequel well basically my
sequel is probably the world's most
popular relational database
so if you think of relational databases
that are table driven mysql is arguably
the most popular
database out there for rdbs systems it
is by far the most popular open source
uh relational database
the entire database is written in c and
c plus plus it's been around for a
really long time um again it's open
source which is great
which means that there are no licenses
or costs for actually using my sequel
and you'll find that companies of all
sizes from small mom and pop shops all
the way up to
massive enterprise global enterprises
are all using my sequel so you know why
would you want to then take that next
step of connecting node.js with mysql
well fundamentally comes down to the
basics of the differences between the
two products
mysql is a database and node.js is a
architecture framework for building out
web applications now again with mysql
it's open source it's free to use you
don't have to pay anything there are no
licenses which if you compare it with
other solutions out there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
is incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there i think apache is probably
arguably
more apache ui web server it's probably
more mature but my sequel is very close
behind it so it has had a huge amount of
investment this is not a solution that's
only a couple years old we're talking
about a solution that's more than 15
years old
very very structured very powerful
and you can do a lot of really good
things with it
um you can actually then
build solutions with it and using php
java really any kind of database
even
other systems and other frameworks will
allow you to interact with mysql
and it just allows you to work with just
huge amounts of data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and my sql
so i'm going to go ahead and we're going
to get started by putting our load
environment together so let's start by
selecting node.js and downloading it so
go to nodejs.org
and there you have your options for
windows mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
the next is to install zap and so i'm
going to go to
zap installers for a quick search and
it's on our apachefriends.org site and
here we have example windows linux and
mac os 10
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our ide our
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use visual
student code if you don't use visual
studio code
it's a great free open source solution
for being able to build applications
i'm a big fan of it so i encourage you
to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio um code up and
running so go ahead and we can open up a
new folder
and let's go ahead and create a new
folder and just put a stratified desktop
here and it's just for uh kicks and
giggles so i'm just gonna type in
nodemysql for our source code and open
up that folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our visual studio code editor
and what we want to do is we want to
get rid of the welcome page and we don't
really need that anymore
and
we're going to uh terminal window so
we're going to see the
scripts that we're writing we'll be
using tunnel quite a bit um in this so
for instance we're just going to
test that we have npm installed we do so
that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the json file for that package
has been created
so we go in there we can see that all
the defaults are selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default uh file that will be created so
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to create our own index.js file and
we're going to add in some instructions
into that file to actually install the
correct software from the npm package
and the first thing you want to do is
install express
which is a package that's great for
building uh lightweight web applications
not mobile applications i suppose if
you're doing a responsive design
but in this it's really it's a web
application environment so we're going
to
put in
the requirements for that and then we're
going to also go and require that my sql
gets installed
and uh
you'll see that for both of them we're
just going to use npm's default commands
for creating it and we'll go down to the
terminal window and we'll do npm install
and it's going to
install
the express and my sql environment
and as that installs you actually see on
the left hand side under uh the folder
you actually see
the files starting to be installed uh so
for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are
everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these clients make sure that
everything is installed so we're going
to open up zamp which allows us to go in
and
view and see that everything's stored so
we have my sequencer we have apache
installed
we can start and stop under services
with zam go ahead and do that you can do
this through tele window as well but
the
ui interface is really nice so let's go
into
my
sql um
interface and you'll see that we don't
have any databases
these are just the
standard test databases and so we have
to go ahead and create
one and so let's
get our
sql database connection created
so i'm going to write
const
db equals my sql
create connection
and we want to create connect to
the localhost in this instance
and user is just going to be a root user
account
which is the standard user account that
comes from my sql uh there is no
password for the root user when you're
running it locally i encourage you to
change that as quickly as you can
because you don't really want to have
a password free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the mysql
environment
so do real write db dot connect
uh parenthesis error and we want to
throw an error message if the connection
isn't good
so if we do error
we'll throw the
error message
to the log window
and
if we don't then we'll write mysql
connected
all right
and now
we want to connect that to our express
app
the next
step we want to do after we made our
connection
is to go ahead and create a database so
we'll do both steps at the same one so
writing the script right now and then
we'll run the commands uh in the
terminal window so we can actually
create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
a database
and let's write let's sql equals
create
database
i'm going to call the database node
mysql you could call it whatever you
want um but this is just a node my sql
script the db
query
sql
through error message
brains.send
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created
let's go save that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we've created this so let's go ahead
and
do node index.js
to run that and connect it to my sql
that's great
good first step and then we'll go to
window
i will go to localhost
3000 which is
the default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
database has been changed to node by sql
so we've got an error message which we
expected and so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go ahead
and
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the error message if comes out to
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of service started on
porsche 3000.
so let's try that again
there's index.js
yep and server has time for 3 000
let me refresh that
i'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is
let's go ahead and see how database
hasn't been created
so let's go and connect to
database
let's go ahead and click
create db
on port 2000 all right so by doing that
we write that command
and that function and that goes and
creates our database and we'll actually
see
but we have now node my sql has been
created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables we have no tables in here
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see
in our windows so all of the work that
we're doing for creating a table for
creating the database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through js and so here we are
going to create a new table and call it
creating it's going to be called the
employee table and so once we run the
command create employee it's going to
create a table has the employee fields
which is going to have an
id which will be an integer that will go
into auto increment they'll have a name
field
and we'll also put in a designation
and
i will have a primary key as well
keep it very simple right now
and let's just
put a db connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so
everything goes correctly then we'll
have the message employee table created
so let's test this out
and
node.xjs
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to
so we've got node nodemysql so we're
connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again yeah okay
to database so database has the name
and because put note mysql there's no
fields in there yet
so let's go ahead and
put in create employee fields and let's
run the function that creates the new
table
and then voila
we have a new table
and so
the next action we want to do is
actually
populate the table with a record
so
this starts becoming familiar so we're
not going to
put in a single record we'll call it
employee one for right now
and
we'll write the
the function
in an employee one and when we run that
function
uh it'll actually go ahead and
create the lit insert the record into my
sql
and then the name will be jake smith
and the designation
will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own ceo is why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
i'm going to insert into the employee
table
i'm just using some basic sql scripting
here
and what you'll see actually with
visual studio code is that it's actually
providing a lot of prompts to make it
easier to write your code
microsoft is looking to actually add
some ai
to visual studio code to actually start
auto completing
script which will make it even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node index.js
we've seen everything connected and
we'll grab the
function employee one
and let's go over to our express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command employee e1
employee has been added and we will just
validate this by going back to my sql
refresh it
and you'll see
we click on the employee tables we
should now have an employee in there yep
there we go jake smith
hold on jake
first record
all right so we want to be able to now
select the employee
so let's go ahead and
do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
so let's use our sql command
and we'll do select
star which is everything
from the employee table so we're
actually playing everything from the
employee table
we're going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console log
results
all right let's give this a whirl
okay so
let's go and run our command
or localhost 3000
but get employee
and it says employee details fetch now
we go to the console window in visual
studio yep there we go we have now all
the packet information
including the id about jake smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard sql commands
and so we want to
be able to update the employee from a
browser
and as you can tell we're not using
any forms or any other types of records
we're just simply interacting
with between the
the browser the server and
the database
and the new name will be updated name
and just make sure we're updating your
private record
and we'll show that we're matching
against id1
all right so that's wrong
[Music]
and
jake smith is there now go
and select
jason cody
cole1
same slash one
we've now gone ahead and updated
[Music]
the
jig
and jake smith's information
so let's click on play table
and we now see he says updated name i
know not very creative but it allows you
to see a change
and finally we can go ahead and delete
the record as well
so it's going to be similar to update
but i'm deleting instead
we're going to delete
the record from the employee table
right name equals where i t equals sorry
[Music]
and
and then we want to be able to
show that the record has been
deleted
okay
deleted and we go to uh
database
gc
on the employee table
that there are no entries
the one-on-one record that was there has
been deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into my sql
right from
node package manager
you can create a table
you can select your records
you can then
update any record that you selected
and finally you can delete any record
that
you want to be able to delete
we're going to be going through some of
the simple questions that you would be
asked during a node.js interview let's
just get started
so the first question you're probably
gonna be asked is you know you know what
is node.js you know do you know what
it's for and essentially node.js is
one of the most popular if not the most
popular uh open source cross-platform
javascript programs and it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the core
programming runtime and allows you to
build solutions extremely quickly in an
open source mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client size web applications
we'll see this later on and you may want
to talk a little bit about using express
js and how you can build out apis
to work with node.js and connecting to
databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store
data intensive applications that are
asynchronous and event driven in their
model
and this is important when you're
talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you're gonna then us be asking you
how does nodejs work well node.js itself
is actually built on the v8 engine and
the v8 javascript engine is the same
engine that runs javascript in your
chrome web browser extremely fast
it allows for
high output and non-blocking out through
your i o input outputs and is a single
threaded event loop
so you're going to be then asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications
probably referencing the web
applications is a really good starting
point because here you can actually talk
about maybe some examples that you've
done where you're building out some of
these web applications
indeed one of the things that you want
to be consistently doing and peppering
your answers with is examples of work
that you have done now it doesn't matter
if those examples are purely
experimental or
training examples that you've done the
fact that you've actually worked with
node.js and created a distributed system
or a web application is really valuable
because it shows that the person that
you're meeting with that you have
knowledge and understanding and
practical experience of applying the
theory of working with node.js with the
practice of working with node.js
so be asked about you know your answer
essentially the i o refers to the
transfer of data in and out of uh a
system and that's really it you know
there's a reason why google calls their
conference io it's the transfer of data
in and out of our brains at that
conference the application is same here
it's about moving data in and out of
systems through using node.js
and that every um event can be tracked
and whether it's on a physical device a
network or files within a system again
it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
gonna be asked yo can you explain the
difference between front-end and
back-end development and this is a
question that i can ask a lot when i'm
meeting with clients um you know people
get really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development um bottom line
front-end is what gets resolved inside
of your web browser or the app on your
mobile device back end is what gets
resolved um essentially um what we call
the the back office or server side
applications but it's becoming more and
more synonymous for what gets run in the
cloud
so web applications um really get a lot
of the functionality of a web
application gets run in the front end
anything with css html5 uh client-side
javascript it's all gonna get run in the
front end everything else such as
connecting to a database um gets run
behind the scenes in the back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like graphics is going to be on the
front end
apis are going to be run on the back end
and then just finally some of the
scripting languages are used on on the
front end
so html css javascript those are all
common
core scripting languages that you would
use
you can use frameworks such as angularjs
and react.js or vue
those would be a front end frameworks uh
backend frameworks will include java php
python
and node.js or some of the backend
technologies you'd also
throw in there
net as well i mean it's just the whole
you know litany of front-end and
back-end technologies and frameworks
that you can use um and this is actually
a good point to kind of explain the
experience you have outside of just
working with node.js but other
technologies that you've been working
with that potentially that the client is
also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you can respond is do
you mean node package manager and the
reason why you want to respond like that
is that you want to qualify their
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them
includes references to mpm
so you're gonna be asking you know so
okay you've told me um what it is you
know can you go into a little bit more
um details you know can you provide two
main functionalities and so one of them
is being able to
manage online repositories of modules
and packages
so you can go to like search.nodejs.org
and you can find a packages that you can
install into your solution
such as
js
and it also provides a command line
utility that allows you to manage
your packages very quickly uh through
terminal window or command line
i use vs code a lot visual studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules
in node.js they're essentially like
javascript libraries so you can think of
some of the javascript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance
if we're creating a web server you can
actually use the require commands to be
able to require that the server be there
so the example we have on the right hand
side uh shows that we really do need to
have http which is a web server and we
require that to be installed and so that
if you're running that
npm package it will actually install the
http server and then you actually write
some code to actually then listen on uh
the localhost port 2000 for where you'll
be running your application
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that come
with node.js right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we were also referenced just
earlier on http is a core module for
running a
web server
you have a utility function that is
useful for developers to
assess and features within your node.js
project you have a url
module for any url passing you'd be
doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's being worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep
your storage of files
to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over back-end technologies
such as java and php and particularly
gyro it's a very mature stable language
it's been around for more than 20 years
you know php um runs some of them the
most powerful and largest uh websites
out there such as facebook so why would
you use node.js well the first response
is kind of a gimme but it is really fast
and if you watched any of the videos
that we've done on node.js
building out solutions and developing
the solutions you'll see just how fast
it is
the second is the
really kind of the secret sauce with
node.js is the node package manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as express
or as a database into your
solution
really quickly and there's over 50 000
bundles available for node package
manager
if you're building out a
real-time application that's data
intensive and you need to have apis
quickly developed then node.js is
another great it's really the great
solution for you it allows you to build
out these solutions really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client due to
the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up node.js because you have that common
language of javascript
and on top of that javascript is the
world's most popular
scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular and node.js
and so and the reason why this question
may come up is the person interviewing
you is seeing whether or not you do know
the difference between a front-end
framework and a back-end framework and
this is one of those questions where you
can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other
so angular is a front-end development
framework whereas node.js is a
server-side in framework other
differences though between the actual
frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of javascript nodejs is
written in c and c plus
angular is used for building out single
page
client-side web applications and so
that's a key word there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side network
applications and so
again the two complement each other
uh angular splits web applications into
the mvc and model view control
components whereas node.js generates a
lot of database grades it does more than
that as well but you can think of no jss
that glue to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so um you're going to
probably be asking what is
the most popular database used with
node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database
mysql is also very popular and that's a
more traditional relational database
um you would go with mongodb for really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses
of data that has to be
created read updated and deleted very
very quickly
for
some of the other popular libraries that
you use for node.js express.js is a very
popular one i really like working with
express.js allows me to build out web
applications really quickly
more importantly it allows me to build
out apis very quickly and which you know
apis are essentially web applications
themselves but being able to do that
very quickly with a framework like
express.js is very useful
mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a database really
easy so um here is an example of
express.js which is a in itself really a
flexible budge a solution that you can
do lots with and mongoose which is a
more
focused solution
which allows
you know to you make it easier to
connect to your databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explained this earlier on that
you can actually build out
applications that run on the cloud why
would you you know what's are the pros
and cons so a pro is that
node.js is extremely fast a processing
an event-based model uh it really is
fast a con is if you have something that
is a very heavy computational task it's
not so good at that
now i will caveat that this is that
node.js is getting better all the time
and so
you might have to be provide an example
of what a very heavy computational task
is and that may be
calculating
a risk on an insurance application
against
many many variables that may be
something that's seen as computationally
very heavy but what you can do in that
example is you can offload the task to
another solution that's designed for it
and use apis to pass the data back and
forth
pro
javascript is used for building out your
applications with
node.js great lots of people know
javascript
a
restriction and again this is evolving
as javascript itself evolves is that
when you do a callback you may end up
doing lots of nested callbacks
if you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that i always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier
how do you get around that barrier and
so for instance when you're talking to
your recruiter
you can say look the reason why i use
node.js is that it's fast it's
event-based driven i can use javascript
uh there are some challenges and but
what i do to get around those challenges
are and that's where you can say that
you know you may
run the complex script off and you may
write that in net or java or php and
then use an api to do the response back
into node.js so you get the benefits of
both worlds but minimize the investment
in having to manage a complex
environment such as java versus a
relatively simple environment with
node.js
the node package manager makes it
extremely easy to access just an awful
lot of functionality with over 50 000
packages there's a package for that
so from being able to have a
tool that creates unique identifiers
that you might need to have for
generating content that gets posted into
a database through to being able to
connect to databases through you know to
running so many different solutions and
the npm package manager with this access
to so many different packages makes it
great
for um getting access to all that
content now con is working with
relational databases with node.js isn't
as easy as a nosql database now you can
do it and there are ways around that and
what i would do when this question comes
up is always kind of pivot to say hey
this is how you can actually then
get around building out that application
pro for node.js designed for streaming
huge amounts of data in and out a con is
that node.js is single threaded and so
it can be cpu intensive
but again there are ways around that and
a good way around that is scaling your
solution in elastic environments such as
the cloud
so what is the command used to import an
external library and so to import an
external library the command is the
required command so an example we have
here is uh you can start a variable and
the variable's going to be for http and
you're going to then require the http
service and that means that the
application itself won't run unless the
external library the http library is
installed
okay so those were our introductory
questions for node.js let's kind of
pivot and take a look at the
intermediate questions that you would be
asked
so what does event driven programming
mean
so event driven programming means that
if something happens something else will
happen in response so for instance if
you click a mouse
that mouse click is an event that means
something has to respond to that event
uh just think of it as cause and effect
it's just the basic motion of physics so
that's what event driven programming
means
you also look at it as a callback
function
so that when an element is executed
something will happen in response
so what is an event loop in node.js
so an event loop in node.js is when you
do an asynchronous call and
what that essentially means is that
you are sending out
data and then non-blocking input output
from node.js is pulling data back in
what is an event emitter in node.js so
an event emitter has really two areas of
focus one is that it manages uh the
classes that hold all the objects uh
within your event and we have an example
of this on the right hand side
and then whenever an event actually is
thrown uh the functions are then called
on that event synchronously
so for instance we have in our example
on the right hand side we create an
event and then we have the functions and
that executed in a series from
that event
so let's talk about the api functions in
node.js so there's two types
one is an asynchronous non-blocking
function
and the second is a synchronous blocking
function and the difference between the
two of them is asynchronous is that
there is no structure to the order
for how the
api is resolved synchronous means that
when the feedback from the api is
received you have to execute
the response in a series for how the
response is sent to
you so what is a package.json file so
the package.json file is at the heart of
our node.js
package when we actually will initialize
a solution a folder to be a node.js
package
you'll find that the package itself
holds all of the metadata that's
particular to the project you're working
on such as project name version
requirements it is you have to have
installed in the root of the directory
for the project and again look at any of
the videos that we have on node.js we do
have demonstrations within those videos
that actually then go through and break
out
how to create that root package and
you'll see how you can actually then go
ahead and update the instructions or the
metadata within the package
so here we have an example of what that
metadata looks like so again this kind
of continues that question of what is a
package.json file and you may be asked
you know what is the metadata and why is
it important and the metadata is a
basic
json collection of pairing of
key details such as name version
description and then the custom version
that you put so for instance under name
you could create a name for your project
there can't be any spaces what is the
version and description
and what is the main or starting path
for the solution typically that would be
index.js but it could be anything.js
but index.js is typical simply because
index.html
is the starting point for a typical web
application
so how would you use a url module in
node.js
so with the url module what it allows
you to do is really two things one is
that it provides the resolution and
passing of a url
for utilities in your application
and then it allows you to
extend your module with built-in
solutions and split up the web address
into a readable format
so in this example
we have the url and the response it
would give for that url which would then
be a year and month um and it'd be in a
readable format so it would read out as
2020 and then the month
so what is express.js and you've heard
me mention this a couple of times in the
video we actually have a separate video
on express.js um but express.js is a web
application framework that allows you to
build out web solutions
for both mobile and traditional desktop
right inside of node.js so it's very
easy to use
being able to install web.js is as
simple as requiring express to be
installed in the example that we have
here on the screen it's a full solution
of showing how to actually build out a
solution with web.js
so in this example
you start off the first two lines
require express to be installed and the
store comes from node packet manager
then we have a simple application that
will then send to the browser window
a hello world message confirming that
express is up and running and then the
third block of content starting with
virus server actually will define the
port
where your application is going to run
so in this instance
the port is going to run on
localhost and the
port will be port 8081
and so you can actually go to localhost
colon8081
and when you do that that will trigger
the application that will forward up the
message hello world and it's all coming
from express.js
so what are streams and node.js so
streams are objects that allow you to
read and write data continuously back
and forth within your application and
there's really four different types of
streams there's readable writable duplex
and transform
the readable stream through which data
can be read
uh the writable streams that you can
actually write to
a duplex is a stream where it is both
readable and writeable
and
transform our streams that can be
manipulate the data
while it is being read or written
so how do you update and delete a
dependency so say for instance we want
to install
something like express so if you wanted
to install express what you would do is
you would just write them inside of your
project you want to go to terminal
window and write in the command mpm
install express
if you want to update the dependencies
within your node package manager to
update all of them all you have to do is
write the command npm update all
dependencies
and then if you want to explicitly
uninstall a dependency such as
express.js
that's using the uninstall command and
so that would again be going to terminal
window and you would type npm uninstall
express
again it's really easy to create a
simple server in node.js that will run a
simple command
the http service is actually built into
node.js you don't need to use express.js
i typically use express.js when i want
to do a web server because typically
what i find is that i will want to go
and do something more complicated but if
you want to do something that
illustrates just the core functionality
within node.js you can actually just
require the core http service that
actually comes as part of node.js and
then you can actually then go ahead and
tell it to create a service and then to
write in plain text a command or text
string such as in this case it'll be
hello world and that would pop out and
then the final line is to then uh listen
that if you go to a web browser that's
on port 127.0.0
or localhost
and go to
port colon 8080. once you actually go to
that that will trigger this application
and you'll get the text hello world pop
up on your screen
so explain synchronous and non-blocking
apis in node.js
so
all the apis
in node.js are asynchronous which means
that they are non-blocking which means
you can run them continuously
and scale around that which is just
fantastic it's one of the reasons why
node.js can scale so fast and the ape
means that the apis can return data send
data after it's been called and really
increase the efficiency of events as
they are triggered within node.js
so how do you implement async and
node.js and so the example that we have
on the left hand side allows us to
trigger async and it's using the async
function and as you can see in this
example
it's actually something that can be done
very quickly in this example we're
actually making a command to logo host
and app that's running on port 3000 and
then depending on
what we get if there's an error message
and then we'll have error message go to
the console log which is the terminal
window and if
we get a response to an application uh
then we'll actually get a positive
response which would be fetched response
uh so
again very quickly and easy that you use
the async function uh to be able to
build out and you to get your
asynchronous code
so what is the purpose of module exports
so
a module export is a way to encapsulate
your the entire code for a solution in a
single package in a single file and then
you can then
share that with other developers so
you're all working from the same
environment
so what is a callback function in
node.js a callback function is
essentially that once you run and you've
triggered an event and the response has
been given
you want to be able to then have a
callback to validate that the task is
complete all right let's move on to the
final set of questions which is advanced
node.js questions
so what is repple in node.js so repl
stands for read eval print and loop and
this is a reference to the
unix and linux background that node.js
has
so rapple will form the following tasks
the reader will be actually
passing the javascript you'll read that
and store it in memory eval
takes and evaluates the data structure
print will then print the results often
on the console window or onto a web page
and then loop and loops the above
command until the user presses ctrl c
twice
what is the control flow function
so the control flow function is a piece
of code that runs between several of the
asynchronous functions and that's it it
actually controls how those functions
execute
so how control flow controls the
function calls and it does it through
four ways one is it controls the order
of execution
it collects the data it limits the
concurrency and then it also calls the
next step in a program again this is a
management tool for how your functions
are called within node.js
so what is the difference between fork
and spawn methods in node.js
so the essential difference between the
two of them is that if you use the fork
method it will actually trigger and
create a new instance of the v8 engine
the engine running nodejs and will then
run the application in that new instance
with spawn
it's somewhat similar it doesn't
actually generate a new v8 instance so
it's actually creating a new process but
it's within the same v8 instance as the
previous application that it was spawned
from
explain to me what is the use of buffer
class in node.js
so with the buffer clouds what you're
looking at doing is you're actually
controlling the raw data of a set of
arrays and integers
and the memory allocation outside of the
v8 heap buffer class is used because
pure javascript is not compatible with
binary data
what is piping in node.js
so
piping is the ability to connect the
output of one stream to another stream
that could be a data stream it could be
any stream that you're working with
but it does normally get used to pass
data from one stream to another
so what are some of the flags used in
the rewrite operation files
so r dash is used for read w's for
opening a file for writing
a dash is opening a file for appending
so the collection that you have here you
don't have to really memorize all of
them but to have a few of them in the
back of your mind is always a good
reference point
so how would you open a file using
node.js
so
the syntax you would use would be the
fs.open and that would then open up a
file
explain to me what callback hell is
so callback hell also known as the
pyramid of doom is when you have too
many
nested unreadable and unmanageable
callbacks intensively cycle within each
other and they're constantly reading to
each other and they're not able to
resolve the solution
and
this is a you know it's a big problem
and this is what why it's called
callback hell because you're not able to
finalize the the app you're working on
what is a reactive pattern in node.js
and so reactor pattern is a concept of
non-blocking i o operations
can you explain to me the test pyramid
for node.js so the test pyramid and this
is standard for testing
for all devops is really split into
three key areas you have unit tests
integration tests and then end to end or
e2e tests
the unit tests are tests that you
actually do in your raw code
that you're working on and the goal
there is to be able to validate the code
you're writing is consistently working
integration allows you to
have tests that integrate your raw code
that you're working with in your
application with other areas of an
application and then end to end is the
whole
system the whole interface as it were
for your solution
describe the exit codes of node.js
so annexa code is a specific code that
identifies
the end of a specific process and
examples of exit codes are unused
uncalled fatal exception
fatal error
internal javascript evaluation area
these are all good examples of exit
codes
so what is
a middleware can you explain the concept
of middleware in node.js
so
with middleware it is the ability to be
able to connect to a system and get data
from it
that's outside of node.js so
this may be executing a type of code or
updating and modifying a request in
response to a specific type of object
and finishing the request response cycle
can you explain to me what are the types
of http requests that you may use when
working with nodejs
there are actually quite a lot but four
of them that you might use would be get
post
head and delete
and these are if you've done any web
application before particularly worked
with forms inside of a web application
you're probably very familiar certainly
with get and post
again it's the request to retrieve data
post is generally used for changing
stating and data
head is similar to get um but also ask
for a response if there's no body
content so if you're using if you're
developing an api this would be a good
one to use and
delete is used to delete the
predetermined source
so how would you connect to mongodb
database and with node.js and you use
that using the client and the
example we have on the left hand side
and illustrates that
what is the use of node unscore emv
and so this node underscore emv is an
environmental variable that stands for
node environment in express server so
the example we have on the right hand
side allows you to illustrate how you
would do that for say a production
environment
so what are some of the various timing
features in node.js so
the timing functions that you could use
here set timeout and then clear timeout
and you to schedule code execution that
you'd have inside of your application
you also have set interval clear
interval to execute a block of code up
multiple times in your application
set intermediate and clear intermediate
to
execute code and that is at the end of
your application
in this video we'll understand what
exactly mongodb is and what are its key
features
now i'm sure you must have heard about
databases but mongodb is a popularly
used not only sql database
now without further delay let's begin
and understand what exactly mongodb is
so here's what's in store for you
first we'll understand what mongodb is
then we'll understand why exactly
mongodb is used
then we understand the characteristics
of mongodb
after that we'll understand the working
of mongodb and how it functions we'll
also look at some of the commonly used
applications of mongodb and finally we
look at the top companies that readily
deploy mongodb so what exactly is
mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in august 27
2009.
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called documents it offers
developers the flexibility to work with
evolving data models since it's document
based mongodb allows embedded documents
arrays and represents complex
hierarchical relationships using a
single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed
as a result massive data migrations can
be ruled out but you must be wondering
when there's something like sql why is
no sql or mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility
mongodb's notion of documents that can
contain documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation
native aggregation allows its users to
extract and transform data from mongodb
and either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document-oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding and
architect can share load between
different instances and achieve both
read and write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the shard balancer
[Music]
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated
across a replica set without complicated
setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is json now json is widely used
across the web for front end and api
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs now the data is
stored in the bson format at the back
end mongodb converts json data into a
binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data
now all of these documents are stored in
a collection
these collections hold multiple
documents and since mongodb is
schema-less the documents in one
collection need not be similar now again
these collections are stored in the
entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data this makes fetching of data
extremely efficient when compared to
other databases now you must be
wondering where exactly mongodb can be
applied or used so let me help you with
that several areas of technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are internet of things mobile
applications real-time analysis
personalization
catalog management and content
management now all said and done let's
look at some of the companies that use
mongodb currently
companies like toyota sap astrazeneca
adobe verizon cisco
barclays and google among others readily
deploy mongodb as their database
management system in this video i'm
going to help you install and set up
mongodb on your windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here
you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under
software and
you can see that the current version is
4.4.4
and the platform is windows and make
sure that the package is msi all right
now go ahead and
press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your c drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed
and inside of it you have the server
folder and then you have the 4.4 folder
and then you have the bin folder right
so here you have the application that is
your and the mongod applications
both are executable files now the
mongodb file or the application is the
daemon process now this is the
background process that make sure you
retrieve the data from the database
access the data so it does all the
background tasks so after the
installation now you need to create a
path to this file by doing this you
don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just uh
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path
and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
i've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on ok
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
command prompt and run the file so
here you can just directly type
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say
[Music]
and here you can see
that your
server has been generated
and with this you know that your in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type
show
dbs
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial we
will be learning
what mongodb is all about and their
advantages and some practical
demonstrations so let's get started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is a mobile db so as
we know the mongodb is known to be a
call a traditional
document based database
okay which stores a data in a document
okay nosql means
it doesn't says like no to sql
instead it says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
hierarchical relationship using the
single records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema-less
environment
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized environment
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql
so it is completely into the
non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database
uh you talk about
a typical nosql
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns a traditional idbs
approach if you see
there they are using a complete table
structure like they talk about columns
they talk about rows and are all about
so here
in nosql it stores the relationship data
in the documents so the different type
of nosql databases are available like
you talk about called document based you
talk about key value base you talk about
white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql
but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobo db installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on
the first option called mongodb
installation
[Music]
okay
see mongodb installation is very simple
if you open a website
and go for
this website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform however you can select
depends on which platform you have it
and after that you will be clicking on
this download
okay so
it will get ready for if you are from
windows
i would say
in this windows
you can
select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip powered portion because it won't
start any mobile db services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want the mobility to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so inside the bin folder
you will see two files one is called
mongodb
okay another file which is available
called mobile
mobile d is to basically start the
mongod server
and the t mobile is actually the
client which will connect with the
mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment
so once you are inside this bin folder
of your
zip file
you will get the mongod so you have to
double click on this it will start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called mobile so it
will get start as a client okay since
i'm using the macbook here the concept
is little
different about how mongodb
can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the mode is being used into your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the
macbook so here to start mongodb we have
a very special way to start with so here
i'll start with my terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database
that is called mongod
and after that you have to say hyphen
iphone db path it is a place where your
database will be starting and one more
important thing i forgot to mention
like
momodi would not start automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts it looks inside the c drive data
inside a db folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forget
whenever you're trying to use the
mongodb so you must make have you must
have this particular
folder structure
in place in your local machine otherwise
this is not going to start
every time you start your mongodb
without this
location it automatically terminates so
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data db folder ready with you
however you could also change the
location of this particular folder
structure for which we will discuss it
little later on but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db path
slash data db
i hit enter you can see now my mobile db
is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now
so here i open the another tab
and type
and the moment i type mobile now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now
to check
which are the databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there
inside your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here
name call
use
simply db
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say use
simplydb it automatically creates though
it is not there but automatically takes
you in while creating those
okay so that means you are in current
database name for simply db
so if you're not sure which database you
are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply db
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous videos you have seen like
how to create a database and
how to identify whether my database is
there or not so if you remember
previously we have created our database
using use keyword so if i just see my
databases which we have created is last
time so how we can check this out we can
say
show
space dbs
okay so you can see we have a got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because
when we have created our database it
should be listed here but it is not
let's do one more time i'm saying use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now
when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason
the reason is according to the mongodb
rule unless we have minimum 1
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now i want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table which is actually in rdb
message is called here it is called
collection
okay
db
is still called
db here
okay that means the database will be
still called database
but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you
like it is a document based database so
here every single record what you try to
insert it is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well
we have to basically go and create a new
collection
okay so what you can say db
dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection
so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say the table
is created and now when i try to see
same show dbs
i can see my database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db.create collection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection i
can directly use this statement name
called
db
dot
db dot sl
student
dot
insert and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db dot sl db.slstudent.insert
and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student is not a
collection which we have created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json-based structure and due to that
it goes with a key in value appears
so db is a predefined keyword sn student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert
the record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property called
show
show collections when i say show
collections i can list down those number
of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language which are there
added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot
sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list down those
number of records which are added i say
find and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say db
dot the name call demo collection
okay db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i
write this command called ssl student
dot insert it not only
create a new collection for me but also
insert the record into my
table also called a collection
that's where exactly
it is giving you the advantage when you
want the collections to be created along
with the data this is the way how you
can really do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
db dot create collection many people
always think about what is the
significance of having this db.create
collection
look
db.createcollection is having its own
significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this db.create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use tbitor
collection in what is insert so you
might be thinking what those cappings
you're talking about let me try to brief
you
when i say db
dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name called support student
okay when i say student
so after this student
additional parameters what we can pass
is this when i say
capped
colon
true
what do we say cap colon true so you are
enabling the capping
after that the next parameter i'm gonna
pass that is known is called size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i'm saying
five two
4 and also we are saying 2 double 8 0
that is the size of 5 mb and here we are
giving call max
colon
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever you try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping so what is that meaning is
it is trying to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5.
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 mb
that means you're trying to say
either
by adding the total number of five
records the collective size of five
document will reach to 5 mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to
say db.create collection this option is
not possible when you're trying to use
this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.great collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogu tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called
relational document
and second is called embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
i would say the parent record as well as
the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db dot
student i do not have a student
collection but i'm just telling you db
dot student
dot
insert
here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
uh
one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we need to talk about
caller name
this name we can say
student one
followed by
the next one i'm talking about which
course the student has registered so we
can say
course
inside this course we would like to say
the course name let's say
course name we are given the course name
called
mca
okay
followed by
another property called duration
okay i'm giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
after that
this curly braces is closing
that means
see the idea is like you see the course
is an embedded document because from
course you have a few more properties
like in course name and duration
i am closing this and starting the
another
property and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here
and from address
and address we can say one more curly
braces
and inside this address we can say city
i'm giving the name called what
bangalore
the another one we are using that is
called state
let me remove this state
colon
ka
okay and the third property we're using
that is known is called country
here is saying
i that is called india
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and outer document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when i try to say db
dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
there also you have option
then what exactly that id is now let me
brief you this id is nothing but a
unique primary key your mongodb has
offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you're inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobodb will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can override
i haven't provided any
underscore id as a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can override
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can overwrite the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try
with some
another record
so the same record if i try to add
let's go
i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id colon now i can give the value call
what one zero one
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with one zero one
now adding it now records are added now
let me call find now you see this time
the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore id
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be
given to you so this is the first way of
how the insert document has been done
will be telling you the another ways
where the other documents are also added
okay so
in the previous examples you have seen
like how we can add the records
but i also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in tv
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for var
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this and within this i'm adding
the first property called emp
id
colon one
after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
uh
you know
the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
emp id 1 and we just give the second
property called emp name
so
emp id
just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp
name
colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here again i'm adding
another one that is called
emp id
colon2
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon3
and
colon
qa
add it
okay and this curly braces is closing
after this your square bracket is also
closing
and once it is done you come down
and say db
dot
new amp
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my
afb
and you can see now it is telling you n
inserted three that is known called bulk
insert when you're inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay
now you simply use
db dot the collection name is what your
new emp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement
so
you understood finally how we can add
the records in a book
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos
okay but here that is the first thing
which you realize it how we can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i'm
planning to perform update on any of my
records how will i do this now so we
have a predefined functions available
name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call a new emp new emp
okay
dot
update
okay
so
what i will do i will say db dot new emp
dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id what we call emp name so we say
wherever the emp id is this i want to
change what the name how can i do this
now
very simple
to perform this what i would like to do
now
i want to basically add few more records
to give you some more better idea
you can see now here we have a call
admin
id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
one two three i just save four
i say five
nice six
okay
and i call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find
now we have total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
[Music]
name
i think emp name
amp name colon
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value
here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do i say wherever
the name is admin change to what
admin new
that name i want to change it
close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
uh the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin called admin
it is not changed and there is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update
so what mobo dv does it starts from the
top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop it doesn't carry
forward its search process for the next
level of results and that is something
which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you're planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a column name admin
second property we will call manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new
underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here
i will put
comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi colon truth that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions hit enter
this time you can say it is saying
and match to and modify to that means
two records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really
awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have one more beautiful feature
available inside the mongodb and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about upset upset is a
combination of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about call update
part you see now
here
we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see what multi true we have
used
now here
this uh
multi true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager 2
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there's one concept available name
called absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset it means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi true
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part so
in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
upset true
when i say absolute rule so what
happened now
they say
n matched 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means
when i try to call this find function
you'll be seeing now we have a
got the another record has been added
are we clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what absurd says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to call the same
thing manager to
find it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager to i will call qa
qa and here we say emp equal to new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and upsorted zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any
uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now
that is very very beneficial feature
when you really want to perform absurd
so that is the
advantage of upsell that is what's
called update plus insert
very
important feature that depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this so the way we have
tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so momodb also helps you to perform
the delete part and how you'll be trying
to add it now let's try to understand
here in my code if i want to perform any
delete part i have this statement name
called db
dot
the option we are using it that is
called collection name emp
new emp sorry
dot we have option number removed
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add
the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
p
name
okay
and then
name scoreboard
admin new
okay emp name admin new when i say
remove
you can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
because there is only
one admin new is available
okay
now in a similar way if i try to remove
the property call
new underscore manager
new underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now
when it comes to c in third part we have
seen update part we have seen delete
part we have seen now it's time to
basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen but
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that
let's see db
dot
uh
new emp
dot
find
clear now so in find you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with a name
called admin
because it is an emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now you can see it finds
one record so like that you can also
apply a condition
okay enter your code
now
in a similar line if you really don't
want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be shown so you have this
function available name called
limit
to two means only two records now you
can see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do
so here rather than saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that out you can mention
so we can just say emp name
okay and using ascending order or
descending order so we can just say
minus one that's called descending order
hit
now you can see it is showing the
descending order now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
that is showing you in an ascending
order so you can pick up the specific
property behalf on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order
so that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on their embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is
let me try to say show
collections
i will call
sl student
and student
okay
db
dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i am talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also
possible so how you can do this
very simple so you say db dot
student
dot
find
okay so inside this file
you can provide the specific properties
like
my outermost property name is called
what address so we are using this option
called
dot
city
so we say
are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name called what
bangalore
okay let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly place is here hit enter
and you can see now i find two records
because both the records belong to what
[Music]
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which
you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than
or whatever values you would like to
make it
is available and possible
okay so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
are we clear
where the range which you would like to
consider
so those are also possible like you can
see we have this property name called
what emp id 3 and 6.
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what 2 so what i can say
db
dot
new
emp
okay
dot find
and inside this file we can say
the property
okay so what's property we're using emp
id we're saying emp
id here
colon here we'll be using
dollar
jt gc stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value called what one
why
close this
run you can see you have received
three records three four and six
in case if i just look forward for
higher than five
you will see only one record so greater
than
that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide
the condition so called limit as i can
say find emp id the way we provide it so
here i will not use
less than
okay
instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me try to take the property call
file and here you're providing emp
id
and then
and we're using other curly braces and
we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details i'm
saying
inside so the properties 3 4 6 we are
comma
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as called working with
indexing
see mongodb is one of the most popular
tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
one particular
document which is huge document in case
if you would like to perform any sort of
indexing inside this how you will be
applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing
and with indexing how you'll be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay so what i will do is in step number
one
previous records if i see i have got
four six three four one depends on
what early records we had it
so we had to call
new emp
so db dot
dot find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three requires with me
now let me try to apply indexing
without indexing if i want to find a
result what outcome i'm gonna receive so
to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me i'll be using this statement name
called db
dot the name is called new emp
dot explain and here i will be using one
predefined functionality called
execution stats
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution starts will
be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon
given the name call
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was
hit enter and now you can see
a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says and return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and returned one that means one result
is returned
and the total number of documents
examines three in order to find this
record
just imagine a use case here
when i say total number of documents
examine three in case if i ever got
millions of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you have no indexing is
available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default
index is applied
on your underscore id db
dot
new emp
um
yeah db.ump dot
when i say
db.newemp.getindex is a predefined
function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the
fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which are the properties are required to
be get indexes
mongodb advantage is it is supporting
multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see
so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply indexing on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about call
collection name call
um new emp
dot
create
index
here you have to pass
two things number one
on which property you would like to
apply okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i'm trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like uh
number of indexes before one and number
of indexes after two that means earlier
index was available only on one
particular property now it is apply on
two properties
if you want you can check
now you can see there's another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
qa
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here
if i see
in my code see it will tell you total
document examined one see now earlier
the number of document examined were
three but since this index is applied
now it is telling me the total number of
document examined is one so performance
is certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes
into your code
okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept
so let's go ahead and get this
implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so
it is also a possibilities where we want
to also apply the index on other number
of properties too as you can see in our
existing database okay an existing
collection my collection name is new emp
which contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name
just now we have applied index on our
emp name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i'll be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
properties now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db dot collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name
of which property we are applying so
here using emp id
and in this emp id we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we are saying
minus one
okay
now let's
press enter and check the status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have created that was 2 and now
it turns to 3 so it is very clear that
index is improving now let's check this
out
uh dv dot
new mp dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply index of
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do db
dot new emp
dot
drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide which particular index we would
like to draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which
index so you should have that particular
index name
okay so here
we are providing my index name so it
should not be uh i would say the
traditional name called emp id no it has
to be emp id
underscore -1 or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found by
the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp
name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was
three okay
one okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so
now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in the previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen how to utilize
indexing into our code now in our next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mobile db
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply
some very simple code snippets into your
ongoing
uh i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate db and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of records are
already added
now
if i just want to apply aggregation now
i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is
see ideally when you talk about call
aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
mythical aggregation there so the unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
uh execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of
functionalities are available which we
will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important
well-known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use the
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
a specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what specific fields from the collection
we used to talk about call what
dollar match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it does the
actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations are available which we will
see one by one in our aggregation
behavior now my first example the one
which i want to execute i have a call
student record with me which contains
the student name
okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student is
appeared
now here my first requirement is we want
to filter
data based on a section a because
students belong to the different
sections
as you can see now it is they belong to
this different section section a b c d
so i just want to
filter the data based on a section a
okay so for filter out i would like to
use dollar match
let's see how it works so i just would
like to filter out those students who
belong to the section a
so how we would like to use it now i
will say
db
dot
student dot
aggregate
and inside this we would like to use
this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this
i would like to use another curly braces
can i say
section
a
okay and i close this
close this
close the square bracket close this
okay so db dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is known as aggregate
functionality section a hit enter and
you can see now it lists down all those
students who belong to the section 8
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records where the section is a and we
are using and operator
marks is greater than 80 there are so
many students who have a different marks
like 70 19 and whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now
remember not only the section a
but also marks were greater than 80.
so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we're starting
this curly braces
okay
so
after this match we would like to bring
and
we say dollar
and again colon again we are starting
this square bracket now
okay we talk about what
section a
number one
and after the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks
colon and once again
they would like to start
curly braces and here we use
dollar
gt that is called what
a greater than colon
okay all are closed
so you see like here we ever got this
square bracket in noun brackets
so
what else is left
so we recall 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
again curly braces
again
square bracket again round brackets
okay let's see where it has gone wrong
so we're using this
db.student.aggregate we'll use this
yeah square bracket
then curly braces then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces and we
will call and operator
after this and we have a call
this square bracket then curly braces
section a
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks
colon
dollar gt
okay and we are using what
colon
after that we are closing this
and using two more curly braces square
bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that
so
db.student.aggregate and like this it
will be able to get it now okay so in a
previous example that was the only
missing point was after this
uh
this dollar match we didn't apply this
curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and i
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this i would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now i
just would like to bring selective
fields not all the feeds like as you can
see we have a call student name
section marks everything i'm getting it
so i really don't want to bring all the
properties from this
document i would like to selectively
take specific property
so
uh let's talk about how we can use this
so we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select
the specific record
so
i just use this statement name called db
dot
student
okay dot
aggregate we're using it now after that
now square bracket
and curly braces
now we are trying to say
dollar
project
what we would like to use dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means i want
those zero means i don't want so
whichever property will be enabling it
by giving the one as a digit that means
it is
it is expected to be displayed so i'm
saying one
comma i'm saying section
column
one okay and i'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one
that's it so now
you can see now i am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if i
go back and
remove some properties like
i only want
student and section you can see i have
only student and sections
are
used here if i just use this statement
name called
underscore
id colon 0
now you can see only
the names
and sections are visible id is not
because i really don't want id by
default id is shown but if i says is 0
that means the id will not be visible
here so like that you can select
the columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way another
thing i would like to use
what if we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
if you see the previous one what we have
used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is the curly braces i'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this i'll
close this
okay
and close this again
again i'm opening it up
by using this option called
project
dollar
project we're picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again
and say
student name
student name colon we're using one
comma
section colon one
and
one
marks colon one and now
closing this
now you can see i got those so the
requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from student
collection where the section is a
so you are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection gives you lot
many opportunities
which you can utilize it for your own
and also it comes with lot many
predefined functions like in some avg
and all
so let's talk about those
functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taking place
now in case if you would like to perform
the group like if i want to find out the
total marks
group by
okay
section like each and every section i
would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how do i basically
do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because i would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces
we want to use dollar
group
okay that is called group by in rdb is
how you use it
here we use this curly braces
again
here we are passing this underscore id
okay you have to provide underscore id
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar id whenever
you're trying to talk about code group
this is the compulsory field you need to
have it
after that
i'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon
here curly braces
again
dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have i want to
use it mark so i can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a javascript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now
section wide i'm able to get all the
marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of records
so hope you're clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
hope you're basically taking this marks
in my application
fine so
we are clear about how we are picking
that up but what in case if i would like
to take a marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but the only thing is
what will be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get
the all the section marks but if you
would like to bring it only for the
specific section we know it very well
what we need to do so here
before i talk about call dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar
match
okay and here we are using this
uh option called section a
sorry
here in dollar match we are giving this
call
section
colon
here we're giving
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section you're able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay so
that's where exactly would like to
perform and there's another option like
in case if you would like to perform an
average suppose if you want to
fetch the count of student in each
section and total marks
and average marks as well as so total
marks as well as the average marks we
want to get it so how are we able to
take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also
into our code how we have taken call
group underscore id section talking
about section
total marks with the sum
we are also using this after that we can
also use the average
okay
so
this is we have taken
group underscore id sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say some marks
after that
we can just put curly braces
and we can just use
count
okay
and after this
we'll be using this colon
curly braces and use
dollar
sub
okay
colon one
okay and after that i'll put
comma here
and we use
average
and inside this average i will use
in curly braces we can say
dollar
avg
okay
colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and round brackets
and now you can see you got the average
markings
in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobile tv that
really create a difference of how
the aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how
when it works with
mobile db mobile db is properly known
for
i will say
for replication that is called high
availability and that feature comes by
default with mongodb you really don't
need to install any software for this
because it is a built-in feature for the
mongodb
so when you download that it
comes along with this so no additional
configuration setup is really required
when it comes to the mongodb part okay
so let's get started and talk about how
mobo db
can offer the replication see the idea
behind the replication is what
the idea behind the application is like
you are replicating it
okay
so when you talk about replication you
are replicating your data to where the
multiple child so here in mobile db we
have one concept available
okay that is known as call master
okay
and
slaves
okay master is one and there will be
multiple slaves
okay so these slaves where your records
are actually stored and this is a master
which will be responsible to replicate
the data to all its childs when the
request comes due to that
in case if one particular
node
fails so automatically the data will be
taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and node slave process so to make this
possible to be a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have one concept like
called mongodb atlas so there we can go
and get our cluster ready so here we
start with the concept name called
db atlas
let's search for mobile db atlas and
here i see mobile db atlas database as a
service see this is a free
tool
it's the cloud environment where you
really don't need to install mobo db in
your local machine it is a cloud-based
mongodb support which is free to use
with a limited amount of space but yes
for the testing purpose it is the best
suitable
so i can start with the start free or
else i can say the login here
okay from there onwards i can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now
this is the place from where you can
start working on your cluster
see as i've told you like initially when
you will be working on this
mobile tv it will ask you
to create a cluster
initially
okay since i already have a cluster with
me
okay so
i really don't need to create it and as
a free
tier it will not
allow me to have more than one cluster
set up ready so if i say create a new
cluster
okay and i say
by default aws
okay and let me close on this
notification aws you can select any
other cloud provider
and
html cloud backup cluster name you can
see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour reason being because i
already have a cluster with me hence
more than one cluster is not allowed in
a free tier cluster so i have to cancel
this
but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default aws
select your location
okay give the name of the cluster you
want to give anything you can give it
here otherwise let it be the by default
name cluster and say create cluster it
will take a while minimum
two to three minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you
and your cluster once it is ready it
looks like that
okay so
here in this application you have to go
back and understand what is there in a
crystal when you click on cluster zero
you can see now here we have a got
three
nodes available one is called primary
node which is called master as i
suggested earlier
and now we have a call slaves
automatically when the clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary two will be
secondary
based on
your package whichever you have taken it
you can increase the number of nodes
later on but as a free i'm gonna get i
will be receiving total number of three
nodes available here
so records whichever will be stored
it will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary
i can insert the record and secondaries
i can read the records remember you
can't insert the records into the
secondary so you can only insert a
record only in your
primary record secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you no whatever no data
available no data available
nothing is there because i haven't
stored any records as such
so i just go back to my cluster
so initially
i would like to go back and
create few things now okay i would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the clusters
because when a cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now
first setting is you have to put it
remember the steps first step will be
your network access so in network access
you have to go
and you have to say add ip address
and in this ad ip address you have to
select this option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those ip addresses will be
whitelisted
otherwise what you can do you can see
here in my options i have given
0.0.0 that means all ip addresses are
acceptable
so all ip addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third-party
locations
next you have to talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user there are
already some new users are created but
it is recommended that you to go and
create a new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user
so by default it is username and
password is given
so you can go back and create a new user
when i say add user
you can give
the username as well as the password
as per your own convenience so new user
i'm going to create it that is called
sl
okay
user
and here we're giving call
uh
admin
one two three
so sl user admin 123
remember this will be the username and
password i'm saying add user
new user is automatically added sl user
and we went to three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement
okay network access database access it
will ask you
like you want to create a new database
so i just go back to my project zero
will be on an option called collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection here
now it is
retrieving the list of databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there mrdp is one of the
database which is there
demo db is there a lot many databases
are there so you can go back and create
some new database and connect through
so if i just create database i already
have a simply learn db with me
user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a database in correction is
very easy if i give you the quick demo i
say create database
give the collection name called
sl demo
okay and give the username call
amp
slw employee i can say create
now you can see slw create it is there
with me
so there is no record right now
and once it is there ready so remember
sl demo
and employee i'll go back to my uh
code again project zero
and from here i can say connect
because i want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through here
very simple option available you can
just click on this
connect option multiple options are
there through mobile share connect your
third party application of the mongodb
compass
so
since i already have a shell with
me
so mac os i have this mac os with me
so you can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since i have this mac
os
i'm selecting this line
but i need to replace with this uh
you can see this username
okay
and you have to give the username here
i'll selected this i open my terminal
okay and this is i'm just closing this
and opening up
another terminal here
since i want to connect with the
shell now
so
what i need to do here in this
i'll just paste that
the command which i have it now
username is
you remember i told you
you recall
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
sl user
i say
that's a user
i hit enter
it will ask me the password so i've
given the password admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me
to this particular
see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly i have
it with me
so i'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if i just want to go
back and say
show
show collections
so i can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so
it's up to you now
by default collection which is their
employee so i can say tb
dot
employee dot
insert
and now here we can just add
name
okay
now you can see
some exception is raised
so
you understand
now you can see the records are added
into my primary cluster so if i just go
back and
go back to my project zero where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
[Music]
sl demo
employee
loading the documents
so it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly
you see
the records will be stored
okay
so that's where exactly it works fine
for all of you so we have this
record
okay so when i say
show collection so we have a call
employee
and i say dv dot
employee dot
find
so i can see we have got new collection
name called
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got
the first connection established and the
records has been inserted in this
particular tutorial we will help you to
connect your mongodb
with the front end that is called python
as we know it very well about the
popularity of python in last recent
years it is growing like anything so we
thought why not to offer you
this connectivity where you can have
the mongodb
not in a local environment but to in a
cloud environment so here we will tell
you how to create the mongodb complete
environment of cluster in your cloud
and we can have this connectivity with
our python which is running local to my
system so i show you what few important
things
one by one
so
why python mongodb
we understand mongodb is one of the most
important
database which is so called document
based database available in market and
it is fantastic phenomenal in terms of
speed and the reliability
it is purely
called nosql database
okay and helps you to go schema less
now python is one of the most commonly
user-friendly programming language for
creating a complete web-based framework
so it offers you huge amount of
libraries with flexibility of connecting
wide variety of applications
so we would like to give you the idea of
like how python and mongodb works
together
okay
so you can
use both the
products together to develop
different varieties of
applications which can suits
to different type of ideas now here we
have one of the very very popular tool
available name called pi
so pi is actually the python
library which is a kind of a driver
through which you will be able to
connect with your mongodb and perform
basic operations whichever you expect
okay so let's go ahead and start working
on those demos okay
so we will start with
creating a mongodb environment
with cluster in one of the very very
popular tool that is known as called
mongodb atlas so we'll be opening our
website
and go here and talk about call
mongodb
atlas
i search for mongodb atlas that is
basically the mongodb
where i called database as a service
i'll be selecting the first option
and go to the start free because it's
going to offer you by default some
500 db of free space
i say sign up with google
going ahead and selecting this
okay i say accept
and say
submit
okay so it is starting up now
it will ask you about a few things i
would rather say to select escape
and continue
well it will ask you about which
environment you would like to take so
i like to take this shared cluster i say
create cluster
now here it will take a while to get
yourself ready for you can see it is
offering the sandbox of having five
kilometer free space
and this mongodb
no backup that is the by default cluster
name you can give the name of the
cluster if you want but let it be y d
for cluster zero i'm saying create
cluster
so my cluster is being ready so it will
take a while to get your cluster
set up
so just wait till the time your cluster
is getting ready so i tell you what this
cluster is going to give you
by default two child and one parent so
called a one master and two
child nodes where your cluster will get
ready
so
you really don't need to set up any kind
of cluster in your local environment and
that is the best environment i would
suggest for
most of your development where your time
reduced
there will be no software requirement
because sometimes version 2 version
changes
and you can get all the benefits of
clusters
so we're just waiting till the time the
cluster is getting ready so once the
cluster is ready you will be seeing some
options
where
will help you to create the clusters in
your upcoming demos
so friends your cluster is now ready
you can see now in this cluster you have
got this
environment
so in this environment you will see
there are some options they have given
you one by one
build up your cluster create a first
database user add an ip address multiple
options are telling you now so how to
set up so the first build of the cluster
which we have anyways done
next is called create your first
database user so select this
so it will highlight this area now you
can say like database access
and uh i'm gonna create a first new
database user and new database user
given the username for admin
let's keep very simple username and
password admin
one two three so admin and win123
yeah same
and say add user
now you can see
the user is
created now let's go back to the next
option
it's telling me the network access now
go here
and say
sorry
now see add ip address
and
i'll say allow access from anywhere so
that i can take it from anywhere
i say confirm
now it is telling me about a progress i
select this
and tell me about which type of
collections you want
okay so i select this
and inside this i'll be selecting this
call collections
okay
and
it's getting
ready
so it is giving me some options
well two options that will give you load
sample data set add my own data i'll say
add my own data give the database name
sl demo
give the collection name emp or employee
remember
database name sl demo or i can better
give the name called sredb
sldb and employ i say create
that is getting ready
okay so my database and table is ready
that's it
so i think
we are all set
with this environment
okay
well once it is ready your collection is
also ready i'll go back and click on my
project zero
and here
yeah so once it is there then i'll be
clicking on this option called
connect
now it will give me the multiple options
how to connect
so it will say correct for the
shell or it will say connect with your
application correct using compose
i'll select
the python
python version
3.11 or later so certainly i'll be using
those version only
okay and
in this i'm having this
so i will be using this to connect with
my back end
so that's how exactly you have
the setup of mongodb cluster
everyone so we are all ready now with
our
setup
cluster we have already created earlier
you remember about we have taken python
3.11 or later
so here if i just go back and check i
have a god
three point eight point five which is
python three version which is available
so you can select based on whichever we
have it let's say three point one one or
later we can say three point six or
later so there'll be no
much difference if i just see
even if i just talk about three point
four there's some change but here's 3.6
or later
it is same so i have a 3.8.5
okay so
i can use the same option
so here in my
vs core editor i am using for my
development so here is a simple demo dot
pi i have used welcome to check if it is
working fine so yes it is working fine
i'll start working with my first program
with mongodb so i just go back and say
demo
py or i can say uh
[Music]
py
demo
dot py
okay
and here if i want to go back and start
working on the development remember one
thing we need first dependency called pi
okay what i need pi
and for this we have already
installed this dependency here
sometime back this is how you need to
install
okay so we have this statement name
called what pip installed by
that is the first dependency which you
need to download in order to work with
this
okay
so
that's what we have taken this is
installed by so if you just see
you can go back and start
developing this statement
okay so let's go back and start working
on this
step number one you need to always say
import
number one the one dependence which
you've installed is called pi
so
as you can just say p by mo ngo
that is the dependency we have recently
imported
from
okay let me go back and search from next
point so import pi
from
here we are saying pi
okay pi
and we're also saying import
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
after that we would like to go back and
use the cluster
so we say cluster
equal to
client and here i'll be passing
the complete values the one which we
have taken
so this complete line
i just take it
go back
and here
i'm pasting it
now here
i have to basically replace this
password with admin one two three
okay and we are all set
okay
now
once it is ready
we can go ahead and define db
equal to
cluster
and provide which database you are
talking about
okay so you remember about we had a
database which was available to us that
is known as call
sltb so i can just use the same sltp
there
and accordingly i can use
which collection i'm connecting it to so
accordingly i can go back and insert a
record okay everybody so i can see i
have got this
file with me going forward i have to
tell
so this is what exactly the connection
url you've received now if you define
which database you're working on let me
say tp equal to
cluster and we have to provide in
double quotes the database name called
sltp if you remember we have used this
after that we have to mention which
collection it was so
collection
equal to
db and here we just give the name call
employee
that was our collection name
so once it is ready then i have to
basically perform some insert operation
so i just say post
okay it's just a name equal to
and here
we just provide the properties
like i would say name
so
you know to the json-based database so i
can just use the name
i say
armor
and once again i can just say
email
and uh
let's see
mama anthony email.com
that's it so this is just the data which
i have now i want to insert so i can
certainly say
collection dot because i want to insert
only one record you can see i have open
functions coming up
collections dot insert one and pass
post
isn't parameter now we are all done
let's try to run this
so i'll be running this with python
three
py mobile.py
hit enter
now it's done let's confirm
here into my code i will just go back
and check here inside my
applications i can just go back to my
collections
and in
employee yeah there we go we have got
some records coming up here
okay so these records are nothing but
the one which we have recently inserted
in our application
okay
so fantastic so first example is working
perfectly fine how we can have the
records coming from the python and
insert it there
like that i can have as my number of
records i can add it
so how we can basically add if i want to
add more than one records
let's see this now here and in case if i
want to add more than one records so i
can just use call post one
i copy this url
and paste it below
and i say pause tool
i say
i'm saying
email
i'm one two at the rightmail.com and
rather than saying insert one
i can use insert many and inside this i
will be using this
square brackets
and pass
post
post one corner
post two that's it
okay so let's change the little name
because it's already there
let's insert
yeah records are inserted let me verify
once again
by refreshing it
well now we have a total number of three
records that are available
now there we go so records are added
perfect so like this you can have
as my number of records you can
basically add it in a similar one the
way we have basically used this
i can also perform
the search part too
okay so in case if you want to perform
the search part we have a very simple
statement available with us what
i'll go here
the way we have added this so
in this i'll just
these records which are added inside my
application i would not execute this
rather
i would like to go back and see
now they are basically commented now
and
in fact i would like to use this also
okay i will go here
and find results
results equal to
same collection
dot
find if i want to find a name we can
just use
curly braces
name
colon
[Music]
okay
so let me say print
and pass
results
okay let's run this
okay so it'll print what
the results for me
okay
so
it is just printing what the cursor
object for me saying hey this is what a
record is available to me we can also
change in case if we do not think the
correct result is coming up we can also
go back and
we can use some alternative option that
is called for
okay so what we can do let's take a look
here
we can use for
with this for i can say result
okay in
results
and
print this result
that could be one option through which
you can get the details with you
okay
so what you can do you can run this code
again
i forgot to put this
semicolon here
or
we need to check
well that was my requirement was so i'm
having this
let's try to run this
well i got my result and this is what
the detail which i have available to me
so
very simple how you can basically find a
record and how you can basically
retrieve the records at the same time if
you want to have the specific field
rather than all the fields so here in my
code in this result
okay you can just put the square bracket
and tell which field you really want it
now suppose if you just want id or else
if you want name
you can basically pick that up
okay so if i just want that
id
the only id is printed that's it
okay everyone so you have seen like in
my previous code how we were basically
trying to fetch all the records we were
using this file
now in a similar line you can also have
the option available because see when we
used to talk about confine it gets me a
lot many records
fine and because of that we were using
this loop
but in case if you want to fetch the
individual records
i'll be clear so in such cases you
really do not want to use fine
you can just
use find one
so what you can do is rather than using
find
i can also use one more option called
one and for which
i can come back
just remove this all
yeah so here in this case rather than
using this file i can use fine
underscore you can see this option
called find one
here we talk about
which are the properties you want to
skip and which of the properties you
want
so i can just use this option called
underscore
idle
okay
colon
zero okay i just remove this
under id zero and here
just print word results
that's it let's run
so that will try to fetch some of the
records for you because if you do not
have that id which you overwritten it
will certainly not found it depends on
what you would like to take
so if i just say
this is having some issues but no
problem but you know it very well how it
basically takes
now in a similar line we would like to
also perform one more activity
to talk about delete
so for which what i will do is this i
just want to uncomment it
okay and i would like to insert some
records here
so here i want to add the id by my own
with name
so we already have this name
email
i have it i would like to use underscore
id
okay
so
we have this property called underscore
id
colon
okay
comma like this
copy the same
using it here
and this time
i'm using
name and everything
it'll be taken let me say
user one
here we try to say
user
two
okay
so collections dot many result five one
i'm just deleting it all
and let's try to execute it first
okay so it's executed going back
okay so i have some records with ide one
zero one and one zero two
now here
i just delete this
and perform some actions here
here we say
results
equal to
collection
dot
delete
see the options are available delete one
and delete money it totally depends on
what you really want
okay so if i just talk about called
delete one it will be only deleting one
record delete many means where the
matching records are available to delete
it
fine so i'm just using this option
called delete
many okay wherever the property names
are matched cause quite possible name
sometimes match or whatever it is just
delete many
so the option is up to you now for you
want so the selected name you have to
offer it
whether you want to match it with the
name or whether you want to match it
with the email or whatever it is so that
will be offering it but there's also one
option available where you would like to
delete everything
are we clear so if you're planning to
delete it everything what you can do you
can just leave it as a blank and try to
run this
so collection
dot delete underscore menu
let's check
great all records are deleted
so as i told you earlier also so delete
many means what it will delete all the
records whichever are present in your
code now
clear in a similar one if i want to
perform insert
so you remember about we have an option
called what
insert menu
and here
we would like to pass
post one
supposed to let's execute
so it'll add
the records inside this
okay
and next time what i want to perform
after adding this record i would like to
perform
the update part
okay
so
what i really want in my update let's
take a look update means certain
properties i'm looking forward to be get
updated
okay so
in case if i want to check the record
has to be updated i would first go and
check
whether the record does exist or not
yeah we have two names user one and user
two let's go back and update bar
here
i just
save collections
okay dot
update one
update you can see
update one here very simple
functionality
here you will go
and tell which id would like to perform
an update
i say underscore
id
colon
which i do you want to consider i'm
saying one zero one
okay
and what else
so i just use another curly braces and i
say
sorry
dollar
set
and after this
i use this colon
use the curly braces
name
okay
and
use whatever you want to use it
so suppose there is a user one i'm
saying user
one two three
okay
let's see
it is loading and you can see the record
user 1v3 is updated
perfect
so
your code is absolutely working fine so
you talk about either insert you talk
about what
update you talk about anything it works
so insert update one
delete one
insert one as the name suggests they'll
be taking care about inserting updating
and deleting one one records but the
moment you use many they'll be
performing multiple records so this is a
very simple way like how the python will
connect with your mobile tv in this
video we're going to learn about the
differences between mysql and mongodb
now i'm sure you must have heard about
these database management systems
but do you exactly know what set them
apart
don't worry i'll help you in this video
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there is no set schema to define
how the data is being stored in the
database
this causes lesser data migrations
but what exactly is mysql then
now mysql is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented
mysql is a relational database system
now this uses something called as a
structured query language and this is
used to access data which is stored in
the form of rows and columns
now as mentioned earlier data here is
stored in the form of tables with rows
and columns and each data field comes
with an index representing the data in
the table
and sql is developed and maintained by
oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between mysql and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure
now mysql requires you to define your
tables and columns before you can store
anything and every row in a table must
have the same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents also the data in the
mongodb database is stored in a binary
format called as bson
next up we have schema now as discussed
earlier mysql requires a set schema to
define the tables in the database now
the database administrator is requested
to define a schema which defines how the
different tables are being stored in the
database now this schema is crucial in
case of mysql
on the other hand mongodb doesn't
require a prior definition of a schema
next up is languages
mysql uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set etc
in case of mongodb it supports a json
query language to work with data next up
is foreign keys
now mysql supports the usage of foreign
keys now if you don't know what exactly
a foreign key is then sql uses foreign
keys to link one table to another now
these foreign keys make data retrieval
easy especially when there are multiple
tables interlinked with one another in
case of mongodb there's no support for
foreign keys
next up is replication
now mysql supports the master slave and
the master master replication in this
setup data set from one master database
server can be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb
it uses something called as sharding now
sharding allows partitioning of data
across multiple servers using a shard
key
don't worry if you're not able to
understand these concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
concepts in detail
next up is scalability now sql database
can be scaled vertically while mongodb
can be scaled both vertically and
horizontally now horizontal scaling
means scaling by adding more machines to
your pool of resources
while vertical scaling refers to scaling
by adding more power like for example
cpu or ram moving ahead let's look at
performance now mysql is optimized for
high performance joins across multiple
tables while mongodb is optimized for
right performance
talking about community support some of
the popular github repositories on mysql
currently are mysql js mysql and then
there's mysql server and at the time of
writing there were about 222 000
repositories on github with 7 million
comments for mysql in case of mongodb
few popular github repositories are
mongodb slash and doctrine slash
mongodb and at the time of writing there
were about 177 000 repositories with
about 923 000 comments according to
google trends mysql is largely used
compared to mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well if your application requires
multi-row transactions
like for example an accounting system
then a relational database would be more
ideal
but if you're using mongodb then it is
more suitable for
real-time analytics content management
internet of things mobile applications
and so on
also mysql is a great choice if you have
structured data and need a traditional
relational database
in case of mongodb
it is an ideal choice if you have an
unstructured set of data so you could
pick your choice and if you're partial
towards one dbms let us know in the
comment section below as to why you like
that particular dbms so now that you
have learned about node.js and mongodb
the next session is a simple
demonstration on how to integrate the
two so let's begin hello this is matthew
with simply learn and today we're going
to be exploring how node.js can be used
to connect to a database
so what we're going to do is so what's
in it for you so in this presentation
we're going to go through three key
things you know what is mongodb
how do you connect to mongodb with
node.js
and mongodb is part of the mern stack so
we're going to cover what the mer stack
is and how it applies to node.js
so what is mongodb so mongodb is a it's
a
probably the most popular no sequel
database out there it's cross-platform
and
very easy to scale it's available on all
cloud systems you can also run it
locally which is what we'll be doing
later on in our demo
but it's just a very flexible database
environment for modern
applications
it works on the concept of collection
and documents
what you'll find is
mongodb was originally written in c plus
plus and it is what's referred to as a
nosql database so this is different to a
relational database which is built up of
tables with rows and columns this is a
nosql database as simply a lot faster
and more powerful for the work that
you're doing
and you're able to use mongodb very easy
you can actually go ahead and download
it we'll actually do that as part of our
demo
so you know why connect node.js with
mongodb
well the reason why you want to do this
is that mongodb is a modern database um
it's not
restricted by the the challenges of
scalability that all the relational
databases have
it's really designed for building mobile
applications and websites that scale
into the millions and millions of users
so mongodb probably the most important
feature is scalability
the performance of the database is
phenomenal
and it is extremely highly available for
the solutions that you'll be creating
when you push it out your solution to
the cloud you can almost guarantee it's
always going to be running
you also have the ability to be able to
scale to very large complex
multi-site solutions in fact one of the
very first mongodb applications i built
was a multi-tenant environment and it
just worked really well
and you'll be able to easily deploy your
solutions across
microsoft azure aws google cloud etc so
you know why do you want to keep
connecting to mongodb um i think
probably um one of the other areas that
probably
is often forgotten with is just
the concept around big data and you can
i mean when you talk about big data
you're talking about absolutely massive
massive databases
and
mongodb is front and center for all of
that
you can do your effective content
management and delivery
um it has an effective mobile and social
infrastructure so um by that it allows
you to be able to build out solutions
that can go to all modern day types of
applications and the data is actually
very easy to manage
through your central data hub
and then finally being able to connect
to mongodb is very easy um particularly
as there is a client called mongoose
that makes the connections extremely
easy so you know finally let's kind of
look into how db is part of the
mer stag
so learnstack is a javascript stack and
it's of javascript solutions that are
built for modern single page
applications and there are four key
solutions in the merge stack there's
mongodb which is your database express
which is your server side
http environment
react which is the solution for being
able to
create your solutions on the client and
the node.js
which actually manages the whole
environment it's really an environment
that's designed to make it very easy to
be able to build out modern day
solutions so mongodb is the m in moon
express is the e
react is the r
and node js is the n so again
as you start working with some of our
other videos that we have
here you'll be able to
see how all of these tools
really complement each other so we've
done an introduction on uh db
really the best thing now is to get your
you know your hands dirty by actually
doing a demo so we're going to go
through a demo what i would strongly
encourage you however though is that
this demo really does build on a lot of
the other videos that we've done in this
series uh so uh you really do want to
spend some time on the node.js video the
node.js for express video the node.js
for apis video
really all of those videos help
complement the work that you'll be doing
with this video here you'll see some
real strong correlations plus a lot of
new content as well so with that we're
going to jump into the demo
so let's give our demonstration on how
to use mongodb with node.js
first thing we want to do is go ahead
and install node.js so you're going to
go and do google search node.js and that
should bring up a result of going to
nodejs.org
and here you can download node.js for
multiple platforms so windows linux
mac os they're all supported you can
also get the original source code and
recompile your version of node.js if you
want to
now we're just going to install the
windows version
and the next thing you want to do is
install
your favorite uh text editor i'm going
to install visual studio code vs code
it runs on all leading platforms mac os
windows and linux
it is open source you can edit it and i
like it because you can do an awful lot
with it
uh just a lot of extensions and it's
just a great tool all around
so that's the next thing you want to
install
and then we want to go ahead and we want
to go to mongodb.com
so we can install the mongodb database
so you want to go to software
community server
and you want to then select
the
mongodb community server
uh which platform you want
and where it's going to connect with
and you want to select the
download to install that
and that'll take a moment or two for you
to download and get that up and running
once you've done that we want to go
ahead and we're going to open up vs code
so we can start editing and the code
that we need for our new solution
so let's go ahead and create a folder
of our desktop that we'll use for
mongodb so i already have a folder
credit called demo i'm just gonna select
that and then inside there i'm gonna to
put in node
mongodb
and select that folder
and that's going to open up vs code and
it's going to have our folder in here so
we're going to get rid of the welcome
screen we don't need that
we do want to however open up our
terminal window so we're going to
run that that's one of the things that i
really like about vs code is you can
actually have your terminal window or
command line window actually inside the
development environment you're working
in so you don't have to be jumping from
one solution to another and then we're
going to initialize our package so npm
in it for the folder that we're in it's
going to create our
node package manager it's going to
create our default package and we're
going to hit return that's going to go
ahead and start the process
and we're just going to go with the
default
um
settings
that npm is going to give so just hit
return return return a few times and
that will get up and running for you
and our entry point for the application
is going to be index.js
area that's uh
gs package and there we have everything
this is just the uh the the json package
that provides the instructions that npm
would use to pass the um the program now
you notice that we have index.js as our
leading file so we actually have to add
a new file here and we're just going to
tour this one
index.js so
we actually have a file that can be
referenced
and now we're going to go ahead and
we're going to actually put in
our
default application so express is going
to be required so we're going to make
sure that that
is included in our first line of our
instructions
and then we're also going to
have a path that's required
and
we're going to require handlebars
these are all part of our express
environment
and don't forget to save your file as
you're going along
and we're also going to have
express
phbs
and this is going to be our express
handlebars
and we're all going to
allow
insecure
prototype
access
you wouldn't normally do this but
because we're running everything locally
it just makes it easier for
you to actually get all the code in
and then we're also going to add in
our body parser
and these are all the required solutions
that we need to be installed
when you're running this
package
and so let's save the file and then
let's go ahead and run it so we're going
to do mpn
install
and we do
save and this will install express
and we also have install path
uh handlebars
express handlebars
and
and this is where we'll install
prototyping
and we'll also have
the body parser
[Music]
installed and we're just going to run
that
this will just take a moment or two to
install
all right there we go
so we have everything installed which
allows us to now start working with our
scripts
so we're going to create an app in
express
and we're going to listen on port 3000
and
we're going to have a message then go to
our console log
and we have everything running off our
local port on local host on port 3000 so
let's go and we're going to select node
index.js
and shows us everything's running
which is good we can actually test this
in our web browser if we wanted to
okay so let's start working on our app
so our app is going to
use body parser
and we're going to encode
our
request the goal here is we're going to
create a file that's going to go back
and forth
to
mongoose among to mongodb
so body parts is going to use json to
encrypt
the content
and we're going to do a get command to
get our results
and if we work to if you've seen the api
video then we did that here in fact it's
probably a good idea to actually sit
down and look through some of the other
videos that we've created such as the
uh json
sorry the node.js node.js
for express node.js
for apis and node.js for authentication
before doing this video
we're going to
create a default page and it's going to
say welcome to the students database
the principles that we're putting down
here you'll be able to apply to any
solution that you're creating with
mongodb
and so we want to have
a simple action that we're going to
put on here which is going to be
click to gain access
okay
we're gonna put in the path and where to
get the list from
okay
all right
so here is
our basic web page that we're creating
nothing fancy
but it's going to take you to a place
where you can actually get all the
content now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to go and
pull the content from manga
so run this and open up web browser
you'll see what it looks like let's just
go to localhost
close out these
other tabs don't need them localhost
and there we see welcome to the student
database click on the database and you
click on if we click on it now nothing
will happen so yeah nothing there
so let's make something happen
okay
all right so
let's begin extending our app so what
we're going to do is we want to
set
the views
i'm going to do a
join
directory name
and
app engine
so let's go for our views we don't have
engine yet but let's go ahead and
create a new folder
we're going to call that one views
and let's expand that
actually that should be okay
hps
express handlebars
and we're going to allow prototype
access for express enterprise
so with express handlebars if this is
new to you it allows you to separate
your content from your layout
which if you have developed with
swift for a mobile application
on the mac uh using xcode is the same
principle there but for
a web application
so we're just
putting out here
some of our
default environment settings
i'm going to set our view engine
for handlebars
and
just checking through our code it's
looking good
okay so that provides
that so let's create a new folder under
our views and this one we're going to
call layouts so again this is where we
are splitting our layouts
and we're going to have
a folder called models
at the root of our application and under
models we're going to put in
db.js so the dbjs file
is going to be where we put our
instructions
for our database and so here we're going
to go ahead and we're going to uh
require to import mongoose a mongoose is
a tool in node.js that allows you to
connect
to mongodb
so we're going to require the use of
mongoose and so we're going to do npm
install dash say save mongoose
and that's going to run and install our
local machine so we can actually test
this out
and once we've got this installed what
we're going to do is we're going to
start connecting to a database that
we're going to call student db
okay we're already already installed so
let's go mongoose.connect
and
we're going to call it mongodb
we're going to run this off our local
host
so we installed the
community version that i was just
running out of our localhost and it's
going to run from the port 27017
and we're going to call this one
studentdb
so again with our application we're
splitting out
all the functionality so if you want to
reuse elements you can
so we're going to have a new usernurl
parser
and we'll make sure we capture
everything correctly
okay
so if arrow then we'll
send a message to the console log
and we have either connection successful
or if things go wrong
error in connection
and then if there is an error then what
we'll do is we'll have the error message
posted
okay
and then we'll do require
[Music]
student
dot
model
so this will actually call the model
we're going to create
and so what we need to do now is
creating
under models we're going to create
student of model
dot js
and this is where we're going to do
our instructions for
our student model so first thing you
want to do is we want to import
uh mongoose
express and the student model
so we've got there let's make sure we
have everything let's capture that
so let's go to
our student model
all right so let's make sure that we
have everything so we want to have
mongoose
and
i'm going to create a new variable
called student schema this will allow us
to structure
what our model will look like this will
be a
a new
new schema
in using mongoose
and our new schemer is going to be full
name
and we're going to break down
our
jsons package so
we're going to put in the instructions
for what
the schema would look like so
we have the type we have been required
this field is required
and the second value is going to be
email
type string
[Music]
this field is required
that's the
message error message you want to send
if
the field isn't filled out
now mobile phone number this will be
just a number
and
we're gonna have city
and the subtype will be
let's just make this a string we're just
going to try and keep this simple for
right now
and let's heal this required
all right so here's our schema
looking pretty good
all right mongoose
dot model
and connect this to our
student model
so we want to go ahead and save that
okay
okay a new folder and this new folder is
going to be called controllers
and we have a new file under controllers
and that new file is going to be called
studentcontroller.js
let's go in and
see what we're going to add here
so we want to import uh make sure we're
running express
so express is required for our
controller
we also want to set up a variable for
router so router express.router
and we want to make sure we're also
connecting with mongoose
so we have a connection to our mongodb
and
we also want to make sure that we have
connection to our student model
so mungus mongoose dot model
and our student model
and this allows us to make sure that we
have
this student model
pulled over
effectively for our controller for our
student controller
okay so let's go to router
get
now render this
and student slash add or edit
we'll come into that in just a moment
so we want to be able to
view title and this will pull in the
insert
student
i'm going to use
under our views
we're going to create a new folder
and this one's going to be called
student
and we're going to create a new file and
this one will be
add or edit
dot js oh hps sorry for our handlebar
so you notice we don't have to put the
file extension
node.js manages all that for us
so
router dodge post
so this will be
our we're going to get our content and
then we're also going to post content so
the post will go back
as part of our body
and
there'll be an id
so we want to then instead insert the
record that we'll be creating
so again if you've been
if you've worked through the
node.js api
video
then you'll start seeing that there's
some commonalities here of being able to
insert or update a record
and we actually cover that
using just a sample json package this
really takes it to that next level
okay
okay so we want to put in a new student
record this will be student
and we're going to have that full name
is going to
come from our body
and we're going to also capture the
email
essentially we're going to follow the
model that we created
and our mobile phone
finally with student city
and then we want to save the record that
we create
okay
all right so we're gonna manage our
error message
and we're going to put in
similar messages that we've put in
before
so we want to redirect to our student
list
and we're going to go ahead and create
that in a moment
so
let's create a new file student list.hps
so list.hbs
and here
so what we do is with student list
that's actually going to match then
the
uh controls for being able to
display the records in the database
and then we'll put um a
message if there's an error then you
know we'll put an error message there
and ask you to report the error message
we're going to try and not do that
all right so
now the next step we need to go through
is we want to call a function to update
the record
and let's go ahead and we're going to
update their records
and we do the student.find1 and update
command
okay
okay so we will redirect to our student
list as needed if not we'll throw an
error message to our console lot
yeah
looking good
and again this is just an example
um but uh something that you'll be able
to do yourself
i have with it your own solution
and
then we want to like go back to our list
to
then render
the records
all right
and here we want to put student and then
how we're going to find the record
and
we'll throw a error message to our
console log
so as you can see we always throw an
error message to the console log
error messages are really useful
okay
all right looks good
save that
okay let's do another router and this is
two
we're gonna do the router against id
this will allow us to
get the content
so we are to get information by id of
the student
what you can see is there's a lot of
the work we're doing here
is very repetitive
um
and
you'll find as you create more modular
code that it makes easier for you to
write your code and update and manage
your code
okay so we're going to
get our
view title we're going to put that into
our document
okay
all right
so our next router
is
we want to be able to
delete
a record by id
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to find our records for our
student record i'm going to find it by
id
and then we'll do find by find id and
remove
okay so we're gonna
to once we've removed your record we're
gonna redirect to our list so we can
show our student list
and otherwise we'll send an error
message to our console log
okay
so i think we have what we need
maybe there's maybe there's one more
thing i think we need to do it
i think this is good
okay so
let's go to our
layouts add a new file there
we're going to call this one main layout
dot hbs
and here we're going to put the skeleton
of
our web page together
let's
write this out so i'm going to put in
html
code
and
[Music]
we're just going to keep this real
simple
header
we want a title
and this is going to be student's
database
i'm going to just call students
so
we now go to
[Music]
we're gonna try and find out bootstrap
for we're gonna just grab that
and we're gonna use
bootstrap to get started
and there are a couple of components
there's the css component and then
there's the javascript component so
let's just go copy the
css component
and then we're going to just link that
into the header section of our
web page
so
and then
here's an example of different
components you can create
uh if you're not used if you haven't
used bootstrap before it's an open
source framework originally developed by
twitter great tool
so
in our header
we want to
put in the link to the css
there's that
and
now i need to also
put in our own styles
so we've got here some styles that we
created earlier on
um for
the work that we're doing you can just
paste those in
so we have a box style that we want to
use that will extend the box style that
you get
with bootstrap
all right so we're going to start
working on our body content
class
bg info and so this is actually bg info
is
a css class file from bootstrap that you
can use
and you have the id of box
and again we're going to do
another class
which allows us for our table structure
so a little bit of knowledge of
bootstrap is great here
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to put in
the content which we're going to call
body and this will
show up on the screen
so again for pulling from records within
bootstrap dig through bootstrap lots of
content there for you to be able to take
advantage of
okay
so now we want to be able to add or edit
our record
view title
and the
um
the
the the french brackets allow you to be
able to pull records and content
directly from
the code that we're writing
so we're pulling title from insert
record and it's part of our
router
command
and then we'll put in our form
which will be student
post
i'm just gonna do a basic form here
nothing fancy
we will put in the first
record will be a hidden field and this
will be for id
so we want to auto generate the id we
don't have somebody put that in
and then we will put in
[Music]
our
form elements
so we'll have first will be
a label
that'll be full name
there will be
an input field
so be text in the input field
and
again we're using form dash control
which is from
bootstrap css
and we'll have
a full name
and
placeholder before name so
where we have name there
will actually match up
with
the value that we're putting in our
model
so here we have student full name
so we're matching everything up to the
model that we created
okay so let's do this for
our
remaining form elements
and again as you see we can put this
together really quickly
so i'm going to put in full as well the
email
and we'll do
mobile
and city
and
here we keep going
for group
so
yeah we'll be able to have the
type of
tool for putting in mobile
so as you can see because we're using
just standard html here you can actually
reference external libraries such as
javascript libraries for
formatting the field that you're in
regular expressions things like that
and let's put in our final value
which will be for city
and normally when i'd be writing this
by hand i would actually be copying
pasting
sections of code and just changing the
values as necessary
just to make it easier on myself but
here i'm just typing out everything for
you so you can
see the
whole process
okay
all right so there are our values
of course remember save your files as
you're going along
everything looks good
and we're matching up our values
with our
records
and we will have a button that allows
you to submit
you also want to have a button to select
view all if you want to be able to view
all the records
okay
all right looking good
okay let's go back over to list now we
want to be able to
pull our records so
[Music]
this will display
the
list of students
in a table
right
let's go ahead and format that table
so we're going to put together our
format here but then we're also going to
add buttons at the bottom so we can
actually add a record to the database or
if we want to add or delete a particular
record from the database
i'm going to call this one
create a new student record for student
list
i'm just going to type all this in for
you
and you'll see how we put placeholders
for the values as we put them in
these are our table headers
okay
body content
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to add in
[Music]
an element that allows you to create
a row for each item listed
so if you have two or more items they'll
appear
as an individual row
on here
and again what we're doing is we're
pulling in the values to be able to
pull from the model that we created
earlier on
so this being the data that's been
submitted so we have it put in the value
for the email full name
and mobile and city
we're not going to show id
so it's playing out all of this data
that we created earlier on
so we have everything posted into our
list
as documents
so let's go into a hps file
and
it's our list
let's bring our
file entry here
[Music]
this will be for city
then
this is just a placeholder
at the end
of the list
oh yeah you know what we're going to do
is we're going to add in
[Music]
reference for the id
so we want to edit the document we can
and then we want to do the same thing if
we want to
delete the document
so href calls
student
and then
just delete
now delete based on the id
we go
passing that instruction over
so click
[Music]
simple
i'm going to ask him are you sure you
want to
delete if somebody clicks on the record
they hit cancel then won't get deleted
if they hit ok then it will get deleted
this is why you can actually write
js in line
okay
and
then we want to
close out where
the row will end so how
each opens and closes
the record
just tying up some of the html there
save that
okay looking good
back to our root index file
so
see now
we want to
also require
our model
and then
[Music]
we'll have our
student controller
also be a require
of where it's going to pull the student
controller from
okay
and
this is just the instructions on where
we can actually find
the content
okay it looks good so let's do
node next js
everything's saved we're going to rerun
everything
and
we got an error
let's go check out where our error came
from
so let's go in to our files
this is one that we created
so
error is in
[Music]
string controller
see where's the error
oh we need to
have our much we need to export our
module to our router
all right let's go open up
database
and we can just start
seeing where the records are
it's just installing the latest updates
here
so
we need to go ahead and in our
connection string so it's on localhost
that's the port
let's just double check that make sure
we're
completely aligned so here's our
database connection
and
[Music]
there's our port and student database
and we did this with one go to mongoose
for connecting to manga so i'm going to
connect
and here are where our records are being
stored
so we're going to create a database and
we're going to call this database
it's going to be called student tb
student db sbk sensitive
and connection name is
students
let's go ahead and create a database so
there yeah there's our database
and
[Music]
let's go we run our index js file
and everything was successful
this is good
all right
so everything should have passed
successfully good good good
database connection is good
so let's go to localhost
and here we are so we can start actually
navigating through our application
so we see we have our setup we have no
records
so let's go ahead and create one
and we go through you can actually start
stepping through the different layouts
that you've created so here's our layers
so separate
to our
code
so there's some spacing we probably need
to add that so let's go ahead and just
add that
and
let's rerun our code
this is the fun bits where you know
everything is
just tidying up okay so you know
it puts in one line one space because we
didn't put in the actual html code for
creating multiple spaces
so we're going to go in and select
insert so let's put in
smith
and we do smith at
gmail.com
[Music]
and let's just put in a random
phone number
there we go we don't have any formatting
so we can put anything in there and the
city uh i know where am i um this i'm in
delhi so submit that
hit submit and it takes us to a list and
voila
we actually have a list with a record
end now if we go back to our database we
can actually refresh it and now we
actually start seeing our records being
created and we see the id is
automatically created and there's our
records
okay let's go back
and now we can select edit we can edit
the record
so let's change our city to
bangalore hit submit
all right city is now bangalore
and if we want to we can
add it again
and so this is
pulling in
you know if we do a delete it's going to
ask us do we really want to delete
okay
a little bit of formatting applying
there
and the records are all good so we can't
make that smith jones
but because we need to hit submit
wouldn't update the record
so we hit submit updates the record
we hit delete it's going to say are you
sure we say yes we are
and
it has
congrats that record okay so let's go
back about code
and
because we have everything separated and
actually now just go to our student
controller
and we'll find our delete
you guys delete and we had
a
uh
we had a couple of minor errors there
it's where it's good to test out your
code
okay let's run that again
and
refresh everything
so we'll go to our database we're going
to go create a new entry
let's call this one from john.gmail.com
we'll put in a phone number
you see that the formatting is just
playing from
um
[Music]
our uh bootstrap so there we are there's
john do you want to delete they say yes
yeah easy there we go solved
and we hit refresh the record should be
gone yep it is
and so we've created an application
where we can update applications
we can create an application we can list
all the items and we did all of this
using um just open source solutions
through node.js and that was with using
express some of the components that come
with express
uh uh mongodb for our database and then
mongoose to connect to our database
and so with that we come to the end of
this session i hope you found it useful
if you have any doubts or queries
regarding the two technologies covered
please let us know in the comment
section below thank you so much for
being here keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn